PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT
WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO THE
GROUP IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
THE FACE COVERING GUIDELINES.
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS NORMAL PRACTICES IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LINK
OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS. MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY TODAY'S SIDE TO BE
PERMITTED EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME
TO BE DETERMINED. IN FACT IT
HAS BEEN DETERMINED LEAD
WITNESSES ONE OF TWO MINUTES
FOR EACH WITNESS A REPEAT TWO
MINUTES FOR EACH LEAD WITNESS
AND THERE IS NO RESERVING TIME
FOR OTHER WITNESSES. ALL OTHERS
WHICH TO TEST. MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. ON
THE MEASURES. FOR THOSE
WITNESSES INDICATING POSITION
ON THE MEASURES THERE WILL BE A
LIMIT OF TEN MINUTES FOR
SUPPORT. IN TEN MINUTES FOR
OPPOSITION. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE BEEN COMMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS.
A REQUIRE LOL WE'LL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED. ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN.
TONELSON NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8152 AGAIN. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE
FIVE TWO IN THE ACCESS CODE IS
TWO ONE ONE TWO FOUR ONE FOUR.
AGAIN TODAY'S ACCESS CODE. TWO
ONE ONE TWO FOUR ONE FOUR FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS.
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WILL REMOVE
THE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT.
FOR OPPOSITION PERSIST ONLY ONE
TIME AND WE PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS WILL USUALLY BE A
SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME HE WILL BE UN MUTED AND
YOU ARE NOW READY. TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY IN AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST. USE THE
DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PURDY GIVING YOUR
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. THIS
IS IMPORTANT IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
AN INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE.
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. FOREVER HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HIRING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LIGHT TIMES
FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. SO PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT. AND ALL.
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN THEN BE
HEARD. WE ARE FOURTEEN BILL ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. WE HAVE TWO
BILLS ON CONSENT. BUT BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESENTATION ON ANY OF THE
BILL SPLIT STUFF IS A QUORUM A
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTERS COURTESY ATTESA HERE
ARE TROUBLED HERE THE TROUBLE
HERE THE RUSSELL YOUR ADDRESS
SO HERE LAYERED- LAYERED HERE
NEWMAN. NEWMAN HERE WE HAVE A
CAR THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M
MOVING TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
TODAY- WE HAVE FOUR AB SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE AND AB THREE
NINETY SEVEN OF LISTED ON
CONSENT. IS THERE A MOTION ON
CONSENT. THE MOTION BY SENATOR
NEWMAN. CONSULTANT IF YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CONSENT
ITEMS ARE AB SEVEN EIGHTY THREE
AND AB THREE NINETY SEVEN.
COURTESY FIVE BUT AS THE I OR
CHOI BOGUE. BUT CHOI BOGUE I
WOULD ALSO. THE VESSEL I
LAYERED HI THERE I NEWMAN
NEWMAN I. HAVE FIVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE CONSENT IS OUT OF
WE WILL THEN COME BACK TO THE
TOP OF OUR AGENDA- I'M NOT SURE
IF ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE IS
PRESENT YET- IF NOT WE CAN
PROCEED WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHU IF YOU'RE- PREPARED AND
READY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WELCOME.
THIS IS ALL AB FOUR OH ONE YEAH
PLEASE PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. CARE THE STOCK MARKET IS
NOW THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF EIGHTY FOUR OH ONE TO
ADDRESS LANGUAGE ACCESS ADD.
OUR STATE HAS THE NATION'S
LARGEST LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT POPULATION WAS SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS PRIMARILY
SPEAKING A LANGUAGE ASIDE FROM
ENGLISH. WE ALL KNOW THAT
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND IMMIGRANTS
HAVE BEEN ESPECIALLY HIT HARD
BY THIS PANDEMIC ARE MORE
LIKELY TO WORK IN SECTORS
SHATTERED BY THE PANDEMIC AND
DESPERATELY NEEDED TO WORK. AND
ALL OF OUR LEGISLATORS WELL NOW
THAT IT'S HARD ENOUGH FOR
ENGLISH SPEAKING CLAIMANTS TO
NAVIGATE EDT. BUT IT'S BEEN
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR THOSE WHO
ARE NOT PROFICIENT IN ENGLISH.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S EDT STRIKE
FORCE LOOKED AT THE BARRIERS
LIMITED ENGLISH SPEAKERS HAVE
FACED AT EIGHTY AND FOUND THE
BEARS TO BE QUOTE
INSURMOUNTABLE. BECAUSE WE CAN
SHUT OUT SEVEN MILLION PEOPLE
FROM RECEIVING UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS THIS BILL WILL DO THE
FOLLOWING. IT WILL REQUIRE YOU
TO D. TO PROACTIVELY IDENTIFY
CLAIMANTS LANGUAGE NEEDS.
PROVIDE EXPANDED TRANSLATION OF
EDT APPLICATIONS AND OTHER
VITAL FORMS. INCREASE
MULTILINGUAL PHONE LINES
REQUIRE EDT TO COMMUNICATE WITH
CLAIMANTS IN THEIR PREFERRED
LANGUAGE IN A TIMELY MANNER.
AND ESTABLISH A REVIEW PROCESS
TO MONITOR PROGRESS IN THIS
AREA. THE OVER TWENTY
BIPARTISAN CO AUTHORS THE
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THUS FAR AND
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR
REMEMBER- WE NOTE THAT THERE IS
A LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS WILL ASK
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
ONE. IF SO PLEASE COME FOR.
WELCOME TO STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION.
WELL THE SHALL WE HAVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. TO ANYONE
ELSE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. SEEN NONE WILL
LOOK TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM. BUT
THERE'S NO ONE THERE ARE
WISHING TO TESTIFY WELCOME TO
OUR MODERATOR FOR THE FIRST
TIME TODAY NASA MODERATED
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES FOR AB FOUR OH ONE.
AND PLEASE LET US KNOW THE
NUMBER WITNESSES. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB B. FOUR ZERO ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO.
AND SO FAR WE HAVE FIVE PEOPLE
IN QUEUE WAITING TO GIVE
COMMENT. THANK YOU. AN ALLIANCE
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS REBECCA GONZALEZ FOR
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. BLIND. ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN. MISTER
SHARON MEMBERS MATH PROBLEM BE
AFTER THE EIGHTEEN YEAR UNITED
HERE MACHINISTS UTILITY WORKERS
I HAVE P. T. E. LOCAL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND THE TEAMSTERS
SUPPORT THANK YOU. BLIND. ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT. SURE
MEMBERS CHRIS RESPONSES
POLITECNICA WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN ONE SPORT.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
THREE. JORDAN FOR LEGAL AID AT
WORK IN SUPPORT. BLIND. ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY. INYO CALLING
ON BEHALF WITH OTHER COWORKERS
RIGHT OF. EIGHTY FOUR ONE. AND
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
THE MODERATOR WILL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ROOM S. ANYONE.
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL HERE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM ALTHOUGH
THERE WAS NO LEAD OPPOSITION A
WITNESS INDICATED. LAST CALL
FOR ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM SEEN NONE WILL MOVE TO THE
OVERFLOW ROOM THERE'S NO ONE
THERE TO TESTIFY. A MODERATOR
WELCOME BACK TO YOU AND ASK YOU
TO PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY ON A
BEFORE ONE. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. FOUR ZERO
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE END
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE ONE COMMENT
COMING THROUGH LINE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY TWO YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
YEAH ACTUALLY I WAS CALLING AND
STRONG SUPPORT- THIS IS AN
ASSET THAT ON POLICY AND
COMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATE
ATTORNEYS TAKE ON THE CANNOT
COMMUTER ORGANIZING PROJECT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FOUR ONE.
THANK YOU. COM MODERATOR
NATIONAL CHERRY AVOID CONFUSION
IF YOU CAN ASK ONCE AGAIN IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL- FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. FOUR OH ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE. ZERO. AND
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO COMMENT
COMING FOR ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH I WILL COME BACK TO IT
TO THE COMMITTEE AND TURN TO
SENATOR LAYERED- MISTER CHAIR I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT. BOMB THE
EDT ARE PROBLEMS HAVE BEEN SUCH
A DEBACLE. THAT IT THROUGH A
FORM TO THE LEGISLATURE TO DO A
NUMBER OF BILLS IN RESPONSE TO
THE AUDIT AND IN GENERAL. TO
BOTH IMPROVE THE OPERATIONS AND
TO MAKE SURE THIS NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE.
STRONG SUPPORT ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM AND THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION- I WOULD MOVE THE
BILL. OKAY THANK YOU CENTER
WIRED ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- WILL COME BACK. AS A
MEMBER CHU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND WILL ASK YOU IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE AT THE
START SUPPORTER CONSIDERATION
AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. OKAY
THANK YOU- WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR LEARNED WAS CONSOLE IN
THE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. COURTESY HI.
BECAUSE THE I. O. CHOI BOGUE. A
TRAVEL GUIDE TO WRESTLE. THE
RESTSO I LAYERED HI THERE I
NEWMAN. WOMEN NINE REALLY THE
VOTERS OF FIVE ZERO UNANIMOUS
IN THE BILL ITSELF THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTERS. CHECK AGAIN
I DON'T KNOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE HAS COME IN. NO BURKE- DO
WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR A-
PRESIDENT. TO HAVE ANY AUTHOR
PRESENT. THE RATE SEEN NONE- WE
ARE- WE'RE GOING TO PRETEND
WE'RE RECESSED FOR ABOUT TWO
MINUTES SOON HOPEFULLY COMES IN
THAT TIME. OR THE PHARMACIST
WHILE WORKING ON.
TO OKAY WE'RE
WE'RE BACK- ALASKA COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO GET SITUATED IN.
YOUR. WELL GOING TO HOLD ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS. SHE IS
PREPARED TO PRESENT. ZERO YOUR
AVAILABLE NUMBER NINE WHICH IS
AB. ONE FIVE FIVE ZERO FIFTEEN
FIFTY I'M A SOME READERS SO
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR RED.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN SENATORS. AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY PROTECTS FACULTY
BARGAINING RIGHTS BY ALLOWING
FACULTY WHO ARE CURRENTLY IN A
BARGAINING UNIT TO REMAIN
ELIGIBLE FOR UNION
REPRESENTATION EVEN IF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. MOVES
THOSE FACULTY POSITIONS TO THE
ACADEMIC SENATE. THREE YEARS
AGO THE UC OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT REQUESTED THAT THE UC
BOARD OF REGENTS MOVE SIX PART
TIME NON SENATE FACULTY JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS FOR LECTURERS
INTO THE ACADEMIC SENATE. THE
SIX PART TIME POSITIONS WERE
ACTIVELY COVERED BY A
COLLECTIVE BARGAIING AGREEMENT
PRIOR TO THE MOVE BUT LOST
THEIR UNION REPRESENTATION WHEN
MOVED TO THE ACADEMIC SENATE.
THIS DECISION WAS CHALLENGED BY
THE LABOR UNION THAT
REPRESENTED THE PART TIME
POSITIONS. HOWEVER THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD
DECIDED THAT THOSE JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS COULD NO LONGER
BE UNION REPRESENTED POSITIONS
BECAUSE OF RULES UNDER THE
HIGHER EDUCATION EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS ACT. THOUGH THE
CLASSIFICATIONS WERE VACANT AT
THE TIME THE UC DECIDED TO MOVE
THEM. IT SETS A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT THAT COULD RESULT IN
WORKERS LOSING THEIR UNION
REPRESENTATION. FOR EXAMPLE THE
UC COULD ALSO SEEK TO ELIMINATE
AN ENTIRE BARGAINING UNIT BY
MOVING ALL OF ITS CONSTITUENT
FACULTY JOB TITLES. TO THE
ACADEMIC SENATE. AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY PRESERVES EMPLOYEES
RIGHTS BY ENSURING THAT KEEP
THEIR UNION REPRESENTATION.
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME TO SEE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT JOHN RENDON
C. U. C. A. S. T. OUR VICE
PRESIDENT FOR LEGISLATION. AND
MANUELA BOUCHER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
BOTH ARE HERE IN PERSON TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILL TURN TO JOHN RENDON
FIRSTS- HERE IN PERSON ALL
RIGHT YES YOU CAN HEAR IT ALL
YES GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH-
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN CORTESE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF AB FIFTEEN FIFTY. MY NAME IS
JOHN RUNNIN I TEACH ANCIENT
GREEK AND LATIN FOR A LIVING
I'M A LECTURER UC DAVIS I AM
PROUD OF WHEN A UNIVERSITY WIDE
TEACHING AWARD. I'M ALSO THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
LEGISLATION FOR YOU SEE IF T.
WE'RE THE UNION THAT REPRESENTS
THE LECTURERS AND LIBRARIANS
ACROSS THE UC. THREE YEARS AGO
THE UNIVERSITY MOVE SIX JOB
TITLES THAT WERE REPRESENTED BY
THE C. F. T. INTO THE SENATE
AND EFFECTIVELY STRIPPED THOSE
POSITIONS OF UNION
REPRESENTATION. THAT WAS
BECAUSE OF A LOOPHOLE IN HERO.
IN FACT UNDER HERE IS CURRENT
LANGUAGE THE UNIVERSITY COULD
REMOVE UNION REPRESENTATION
FROM ALL THOSE IN BARGAINING
UNITS REPRESENTED BY THE UC
AFT. MILLER BY MOVING THEIR JOB
TITLES INTO THE SENATE. ALL
THIS BILL DOES FIX A FLAW IN
HERE IS LANGUAGE TO ALLOW THE
UNIVERSITY TO ENGAGE IN UNION
BUSTING TACTICS. THAT'S IT.
WORKERS THAT HAVE A UNION
SHOULD BE ABLE TO KEEP THEIR
UNIT THE UC MOVES THEIR
POSITION IN THE ECONOMIC SENSE.
UC'S ARGUMENTS AGAINST BOTH THE
BOB BILL ARE EITHER MISLEADING
OR UNTRUE. FOR EXAMPLE THE
NOTION THAT SENATE NOT SENATE
MEMBERS CANNOT EXIST IN THE
SAME MUNICIPAL UNFOUNDED. THERE
WAS NO REASON THE SOME
SUBSECTION THE SENATE SHOULD
NOT BE UNIONIZED. MANY
INSTITUTIONS HAVE DIFFERENT
MORE BIFURCATED BARGAINING
UNITS IN THE- ALSO THE FACT
MEMBERS THE UC SANTA CONFIRM A
NEW UNION UNDER EXISTING LAW
DOES NOT MEAN IT'S APPROPRIATE
FOR THE UC TO UNILATERALLY
ELIMINATE UNION REPRESENTATION
FOR WORKERS ALREADY IN A UNION.
LASTLY THE BILL DOES ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING TO LIMIT UC'S ABILITY
TO MOVE EXISTING POSITIONS IN
THE ACADEMIC SENATE. AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY SIMPLY SIX TO ALLOW
REPRESENTED JOB TITLES THAT ARE
MOVING IT TO THE SENATE TO
RETAIN THEIR UNION
REPRESENTATION I URGE A YES
VOTE NINE EIGHTY FIFTEEN FIFTY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THANK YOU
AND OF THE NEXT LEAD. US
SUPPORT WITH THIS PLEASE. THE
SOCIALIST IDENTIFY YOURSELF
BEFORE YOU START THINKING. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MAN WHEN I WAS SAYING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION PROUD TO BE HERE AS
A CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY SIMPLY AIMS TO
ENSURE THAT FACULTY MEMBERS AT
THE UC RETAIN THEIR UNION
REPRESENTATION REGARDLESS OF
ANY UNILATERAL ACTION TAKEN BY
THE UNIVERSITY THROUGHOUT OUR
COUNTRY'S HISTORY UNIONS HAVE
BEEN PIVOTAL TO ENSURE SAFE
WORKING CONDITIONS FAIR WAGES
AND BENEFITS FOR EMPLOYEES AND
CONSISTENT DIALOGUE WITH
MANAGEMENT. ANY SITUATION WHICH
LEADS TO EMPLOYEES LOSS OF
UNION REPRESENTATION ARE
BARGAINING POWER SEVERELY
IMPACT THE MEMBERS WELL BEING
AND IS UNACCEPTABLE WITH EIGHTY
FIFTEEN FIFTY THE ISSUE IS
SIMPLE FACULTY MEMBERS HAVE NO
INPUT OVER THE MEMBERSHIP OF
THE ACADEMIC SENATE SHOULD NOT
LOSE THE UNION REPRESENTATION.
THEY HAVE PETITIONED FOR VOTED
FOR AN ELECTED TO BE MEMBERS OF
SOLELY BASED ON THE DECISIONS
OF THE UC. EIGHTY FIFTEEN FIFTY
DOES NOT IMPACT THE UC'S
ABILITY TO ELECT THE MEMBERSHIP
OF THE ACADEMIC SENATE BUT
MERELY ENSURES THAT ANY
CLASSIFICATION MOVED INTO THE
SENATE WILL RETAIN THEIR
PREVIOUS REPRESENTATION THUS
ENSURING THAT THESE FACULTY
MEMBERS COVERED BY THEIR-
REMAIN COVERED BY THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS AND UNDER THE
PROTECTION OF THEIR UNIONS. WE
pURGE A YES VOTE ON EIGHTY
FIFTEEN FIFTY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU BUT WHAT IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM- WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTEEN FIFTEENTH SO PLEASE
COME FORWARD THIS TO BE LIMITED
TO NAME. AFFILIATION IN.
SUPPORT THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS MY
YOUNG THE KIND FEDERATION
TEACHERS THE SPONSOR THE BILL
HERE STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THE SONG LAW WITH A CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
ALSO AS PART. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE ANYONE ELSE
THAT COULD BE ROOMS- WISHING TO
STEP UP IN SUPPORT. C. NONE I
WILL GO TO THE MODERATOR I'M
SURE WILL BE OVERFLOW ROOM MAKE
SURE THERE'S NO ONE THERE. IN
THERE ISN'T OLDER THE MODERATOR
AND S. MODERATE ACUTE ANY
SUPPORT. ON AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
AND PLEASE LET US KNOW THE
NUMBER THANK YOU. BUT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. FIFTEEN FIFTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE END
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
SEVEN ZERO. AND SO FAR WE HAVE
SEVEN PEOPLE QUEUED UP. THANK
YOU F. BURKE FIRST WE WILL GO
TO LINE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATT BROUGHT
ON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN- THE
PHANTASM BEHALF OF SP ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. BLIND.
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE. ONE
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE. WHITE
ONE HUNDRED FORTY SIX. SH HI MY
NAME IS SHANNON GARLAND I'M A
LECTURE AT UC MERCED AND A
MEMBER OF U. C. A. S. T. AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY THANK YOU. ONE ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY THREE. AFTERNOON
MY NAME'S DANIEL CHERYL AND THE
LIBRARIAN AT UCLA AND A NUMBER
OF YOU CAN'T KEY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. FIFTEEN FIFTY.
ONE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE.
ENGINE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
COOPERATE WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES CALLING IN
SUPPORT. BY. ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY. MEMAKAI EVER I'M A
LECTURER AT UCLA AND PRESIDENT
OF THE ATF TEAM STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTEEN FIFTY THANK YOU.
AND MISTER KERR WE HAVE ONE
MORE COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH THAT LINE NUMBER.
THANK YOU. JUST BE ONE MORE
MOMENT PLEASE.
WHY NOT ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS NIKKI CORRAL
I'M A LIBRARIAN AT THE UCLA
LIBRARY ALSO SECRETARY
TREASURER IF YOU SEE A OF TEA
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB. FIFTEEN SIXTY. AND MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM- SAYING THAT
THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS LAST THERE'S ANYBODY
HERE WANTS TO TAKE IN
OPPOSITION POSITION. A TO THIS
BILL SO PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
SCENE NO ONE- WE WILL LOOK TO
THE SPILLOVER ROOM. THERE'S
NOBODY THERE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IT WILL COME BACK TO MODERATOR
AND ASK FOR YOU TO QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY TO A. B.
FIFTEEN FIFTY. FOR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. FIFTEEN
FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE TEN ZERO. AND AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE ONE COMMENT COMING
THROUGH A LINE ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MISTER MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MICHAEL THE
DART ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA ALL
THE PRESIDENT- CAN I HAVE THAT
TWO MINUTES OR SO TO. SPEAK
OPPOSITION JUST. HER NAME AND
ASIAN YOUR- WE GENERALLY DON'T
DO THAT IN THIS COMMITTEE BUT
SEEN THAT THERE'S- NO OTHER
OPPOSITION WITNESSES- IN A
ALLOW YOU TO DO THAT- BUT WE
WILL LIMIT TO TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU SIR- THIS BILL
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGES THE
ACADEMIC SENATE WHICH IS A
CRITICAL PARTNER ENSURE
GOVERNANCE MODEL MANAGEMENT
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. FANS
ALSO UNNECESSARY SENATE MEMBERS
CAN ALREADY UNIONIZED AND THE
SENATE THE SPECIALTY
ASSOCIATIONS REPRESENTING
MEMBERS OF THE UC SANTA CRUZ
ACADEMIC. FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS. THIS IS A PROUD UNION
EMPLOYER AND DOES NOT ENGAGE IN
UNION BUSTING TACTICS. BUT
SENATE FACULTY AND NON FACULTY
HAVE VERY DIFFERENT INTERESTS
AND ROLES WITHIN THE
UNIVERSITY. THE PRESIDENT'S
OFFICE AND UNIVERSITY ARE NOT
OPPOSED TO ORGANIZED AND
REPRESENTED MEMBERS OF THE
ACADEMIC CENTER. WE ARE OPPOSED
TO A BARGAINING UNIT THAT TRIES
TO BLAND'S THE VERY DIFFERENT
FUNCTIONS INTEREST. AT THE
CURRENT SENATE MEMBERS AND NON
MEMBERS THE CURRENT LAW IS
SUFFICIENT TO GRANT SENATE
MEMBERS THEIR BARGAINING RIGHT.
IN AB FIFTEEN FIFTY ON
NECESSARILY CHANGES THAT IN A
WAY THAT IS DETRIMENTAL TO THE
UNIVERSITY AND REDUCES THE
VALUE OF THAT SHARED GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE THANK YOU. FLORIDA
THANK YOU APPRECIATE RESPECTING.
THE TIME LIMITS SOME- WILL COME
NOW TO THE COMMITTEE. RIGHT
SKEWS ME. WHEN WE COME BACK
COULD TO THE COMMITTEE AND- SEE
IF THERE ARE ANY CONCERNS
COMMENTS THAT NEED TO BE
EXPRESSED THE SCENE NOEL YES
SIR YES MEMBERSHIP PLEASE PRESS
THREE FOUR DAYS I DO HAVE A
QUESTION- IT SAYS HERE. TURN TO
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE HERE
BECAUSE AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING BASED ON WHAT I'M
READING HERE. THAT- UNDER
EXISTING LAW I G. O. V. THIRTY
FIVE SEVENTY NINE THE ACADEMICS
AND IT ALREADY HAS A RIGHT TO
BE REPRESENTED BY UNIONS OTHER
CHOICE SO HOW IS THIS BILL WHY
IS THIS BILL NEEDED IF THEY
HAVE THEY ALREADY HAVE A
CHOICE- T. HAT BE REPRESENTED
BY UNIONS OF THEIR CHOICE- BUT
WHAT HAD HAPPENED. A FEW YEARS
AGO AS I MENTIONED IN MY
COMMENTS IS THAT. WHEN
SOMETHING- FACULTY POSITIONS
WERE MOVED INTO THE ACADEMIC
SENATE. THEY WERE NO LONGER
PART OF THEIR UNION SO WE'RE
JUST MAKING SURE THAT IF
SOMEONE. IS ALREADY. IN A UNION
REPRESENTATIVE POSITION. THAT
THEY ARE ABLE IF THEY CHOOSE TO
STAY. SO THE. FROM THE UNION OF
THEIR CHOICE THAT'S REFERRING
TO YOUR DOES THAT NOT APPLY TO
THE ONES THAT ARE CREAM THEY
COULDN'T JOIN THAT PARTICULAR
UNION. THEY THEY WEREN'T. THEY
WOULDN'T STAY IN THE UNION THAT
THEY WERE ALREADY REPRESENTED
BY OKAY SO. FOLLOWING UP ON
THAT IT SAYS THROUGH THE SHARED
GOVERNANCE THE UC AS
PARTICIPATES IN THE MANAGEMENT
AND ADMINISTRATION OF THE
UNIVERSITY- IT SAYS HERE- THEY
HAVE CERTAIN MANAGEMENT AND
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS AS
WERE A SUPERVISOR ROLE AND
RESPONSIBILITIES- SAYS IT MAY
BE INAPPROPRIATE FOR SENATE
FACULTY TO BE IN A UNIT WITH
NON SENATE MEMBERS IS THERE A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST IN- IN IT
BRING IN IN- THEIR PREVIOUS
UNION INTO THIS PARTICULAR
SPACE IS THAT THE CONCERN THAT
WE THAT IT IS BEING EXPRESSED
HERE. NO I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANYTHING INAPPROPRIATE ABOUT
HAVING THE ACADEMIC SENATE BE
MIXED WITH UNION AND NONUNION
MEMBERS IS THAT WHAT YOU MEANT
THIS IS WHAT I UNDERSTOOD I'M
SORRY COMING IN WITH- BUT OUR
VEHICLE THEY DO COME IN FROM
ANOTHER UNIT THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO REMAIN REPRESENTED BY
THEIR UNION. I'M NOT AND YES
YOUR AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
ABOUT LOGIC AND IT CAN BE MIXED
RIGHT BECAUSE- MEMBERS OF THE
ACADEMIC SENATE. ARE NOT
REPRESENTED NOT ALL REPRESENT
THEY CAN BE. BUT WE HAVE THE
OPTION TO BE A MEMBER OF THEIR
OTHER REPRESENTS SCENTED UNION
OF THEIR CHOICE RIGHT DID YOU
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY CONTINUE WITH THEIR-
PREVIOUS ONE THAT THEY CAME OUT
WITH A NEW ONE THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE AN OPTION FOR WELL IF
THERE ARE. CLASS IF THERE ARE.
OF MEMBERS THAT WERE IN
PREVIOUSLY IN ANOTHER UNIT AND
MOVED INTO AN ACADEMIC'S
ACADEMIC SENATE WHICH IS WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE UC A FEW YEARS
AGO. I'M NOT SURE OF MINE.
ANSWERING YOUR QUOTE- MAYBE I'M
NOT CLEAR ON WHATEVER QUESTIONS
I COULD HAVE ONE OF MY A
WITNESSES TRIED TO CLARIFY IF
YOU'D LIKE. RUNS A POOR WIDOWS
WOULD LIKE TO DO THAT THAT'S
FINE. OKAY YES- I THINK
CORRECTLY RIGHT THERE IS A-
PRESENTLY A RULE WHERE HE'S NOW
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH A CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WHAT THE
TACKLE SPONSORS OF THE BILL-
THREE YEARS AGO THERE WERE
MEMBERS- THAT WERE REPRESENTED
BY YOU SEE EIGHT C. THOSE
POSITIONS WERE THEY MOVED INTO
THE ACADEMIC SENATE ABOUT THE
NATURE OF THAT MOVE. THOSE SIX
POSITIONS LOST DURING
REPRESENTATION. YOU ARE RIGHT
THAT- IF YOU'RE A MEMBER OF THE
ACADEMIC SENATE YOU HAD THE
ABILITY TO JOIN A UNION AND
THERE IS THAT ACTORS ACADEMICS
IT IS PRESENTLY UNIONIZED.
THAT'S NOT THE CONCERN THE
ISSUE IS THAT ONCE THE UC AFT
MEMBERS WERE MOVED INTO THE
ACADEMIC CITY AND MOVED INTO
THE ACADEMIC SENATE THEY LOST
DURING YOUR PRESENTATION THE
RESTRICTED IT TO THEIR ONLY
RECOURSE WOULD BE TO. CREATE A
WHOLE NEW BARGAINING UNIT THE
GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO SAY
THAT IF YOU'RE ALREADY
REPRESENTED IF YOU HAVE A UNION
YOUR JOB IS MOVED INTO THE
ACADEMIC SENATE YOU SHOULDN'T
LOSE YOUR IN. YOUR PRESENTATION
GET YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO KEEP
IT. SO THE USE WOULD ARGUE OR
INTO. TO SAY THAT. AKADEMI AND
MEMBERS ARE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
UNIONIZE WHICH IS TRUE. BUT THE
ISSUE HERE IS WE- WORKERS THAT
ALREADY HAVE UNION SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE WORK OF.
ORGANIZING AND CREATING A NEW
UNION IMPLODING CREATING INTO
BARGAINING CONTRACT THAT TAKES
A WHOLE LOT OF WORK AND TIME
AND EFFORT. THAT THESE WORKERS
ALREADY DONE THEY HAVE UNION.
SO THE HOPE IS THAT. IF THE UC
DECIDES UNILATERALLY MOVE THOSE
POSITIONS INTO THE ACADEMIC
SENATE. THEY GET TO RETAIN
BACKING REPRESENTATION. MAY
AFTER. YOUR PERFORMANCE ISSUE
THANK YOU. SO HOW WOULD YOU
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT THEY
HAVE HERE THAT- BY DOING SO BY
FOLLOWING THROUGH WITH THIS
THIS PARTICULAR BILL THAT- IT
MAY- SEE WORRIED. AT C. IT'S
AND I'M READING HERE A QUOTE
AND I JUST WOULD LIKE YOUR TAKE
ON THIS CONCERN WELL THE UC A.
S. MAY UNIONIZE THEIR
MANAGEMENT ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTIONS AS WELL THE
SUPERVISOR RESPONSIBILITIES MAY
MAKE IT INAPPROPRIATE FOR
SENATE FACULTY TO BE IN A UNIT
WITH A NON SENATE MEMBERS AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY WOULD POTENTIALLY
LEAD TO ACADEMIC SENATE FACULTY
WHO MANAGE AND SUPERVISE
INSTRUCTORS BEING
REPRESENTATIVES SO I GUESS- THE
IN A PROPER PART OF IT. IS MY
CONCERN. YOUR TAKE ON NOT. HI I
WOULD JUST FUNDAMENTALLY
DISAGREE WITH- THE OPPOSITION'S
TAKE ONE DAY I THINK WE SEE
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM OF
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE BIFURCATED INDEX
PARKING UNITS THAT HAVE
DIFFERENT PEOPLE IN DIFFERENT
POSITIONS THERE- CONNECTING
WORK. DEGREE YOU NEED ABOUT THE
UC THAT WOULD PROHIBIT OR MAKE
INAPPROPRIATE TO HAVE- WORKERS
IN A SIMILAR SITUATION- AND
AGAIN I BELIEVE THIS WAS STATED
BY- JOHN PREVIOUSLY- GAVE
TESTIMONY IT'S NOT UNUSUAL TO
HAVE. A BIFURCATED MIX
BARGAINING UNITS HERE THE SCOPE
OF BARGAINING IS VERY CLEAR
DELINEATED BY THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT- THE UC
ALREADY HAS SORT OF REPRESENTED
STATUS FOR SENATE MEMBERS. IN
THIS CASE WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT. CREATING A NEW UNIT OR
ANYTHING YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
WORKERS THAT ALREADY HAVE UNION
SO IN THIS SITUATION THE UC
ALREADY HAS A- A BARGAINING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE WORKERS
THAT WERE TALKING ABOUT SO.
NOTHING NEW NEEDS TO BE CREATED
WE CAN MAINTAIN THE SAME STATUS
QUO WE'RE JUST HOPING THOSE
WORKERS CAN MAINTAIN. THAT
UNIQUE REPRESENTATION FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE
RECORD THE WITNESS WAS JUST
TEST FINANCING COURSES JOHN
RENDON- SENATE LAYERED. I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE A BRIEF
OBSERVATION AND THAT IS IT. BUT
SOMEBODY THAT. REFERENCE TO
DISTRICT AND WAS EVEN MAYOR OF
A TOWN THAT HOSTS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA CAMPUS.
THERE OF OUR HEAD LABOR
RELATIONS OVER A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME THAT HAVE JUST BEEN
FRAUGHT AND- IN MY OBSERVATION
IS WHENEVER THEY CAN'T DEAL
WITH AN ISSUE OR GOES ON FOR A
VERY LONG TIME ON THE DRESSED.
IT DROPS IN OUR LAPS AND I FEEL
LIKE THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE. I'M AND THE A AND I HAVE
SPOKEN SINCE HER- I'M THE CHAIR
OF THE EDUCATION BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE AND THE VICE CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE HAPPENS TO BE
THE VICE CHAIR OF THAT
COMMITTEE AS WELL. TO EXPRESS
CONCERN TO THE NEW PRESIDENT OF
YOU SEE. THAT HE TRIED TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES THAT IT
SEEMS DYSFUNCTIONAL MANY WAYS
WHETHER IT'S TO CONTRACTING OUT
ISSUE THAT COMES AT US AND LOTS
OF OTHERS. WAR WAR AGREEMENTS
THAT EXPIRE GO ON FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME WITHOUT THE NEXT
ONE BEING. NEGOTIATED AND SO
I'M GOING TO VOTE FOR THIS
BILL. BUT I REALLY HOPE THAT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
ONE GAUGE. WITH ITS LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS IN A FAIR MANNER
THAT THEY CAN TRY TO RESOLVE
THINGS AT THAT LEVEL AND THEY
DON'T PUT US IN THIS MANNER.
AND SO IF IT'S APPROPRIATE I
WILL MOVE THE BILL. WELL LET ME
PERCENT SURE THE TERROR. VIA
CENTER NEWMAN. AB SURE I JUST
WANT TO ADD THAT IN AND
REINFORCE CENTER LAYERS
COMMENTS HERE- AND TO THE WHICH
JUST HAS TWENTY WHAT WHAT WHAT
WE ARE ENDEAVORING TO DO. A IS
TO PREVENT THE UC FROM UNION
BUSTING BY MOVING POSITIONS
CONVENIENTLY INTO THE ACADEMIC
SENATE. SO AS TO REMOVE THOSE
POSITIONS AND THOSE PEOPLE FROM
THEIR UNION REPRESENTATION AND
THEIR ROLE AS UNION LEADERS AND
SO- THE TWO. JANUARY TWENTY TEN
FORTUNE WE HAVE TO DO IT THIS
WAY- BUT CLEARLY IT IS
NECESSARY AND USEFUL I'M GLAD
IT'S WITH THE BILL. THIRTY
FIGURES FROM A MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THAT CENA WILL GIVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS. MADE
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. BERATE THANK YOU FOR THE
MOTION HAS BEEN MADE BY SENATOR
LAYERED WILL. GO TO THE CONSOLE
AND ASK HER TO CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COURTESY HI WHERE DOES THE I OR
CHOI BOGUE. TO WRESTLE. THE
REST OF I LAYERED. LATER AYE
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN HI. WE
HAVE A FOUR TWO ZERO ONE NOT
VOTING FOR THE BILL ITSELF
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FIRST
WE'RE GOING TO COME BACK IN
OTHER WAYS FOR JUNE THE IN THE
ORIGINAL ORDER AT THIS POINT WE
DID MOVE AROUND A LITTLE BIT-
DUE TO A- LACK OF AUTHORS
PRESENT EARLIER WITH ALL THE
PROBLEM ANYMORE. SO WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO A. B. SIX EIGHTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE- IN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU'RE WELCOME
2% WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU AND TERRENCE SANDERS I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING AN
AMENDMENT REQUESTING BY THE
COMMITTEE TO CHANGE MENTIONS OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WITH
UNDER RESOURCE COMMUNITIES
ALONG WITH THE APPROPRIATE
CROSS REFERENCES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A
GLOBAL LEADER IN COMBATING
CLIMATE CHANGE OUR STATE HAS
LED THE WAY AN AGGRESSIVE
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS WHILE
pEXPANDING OUR ECONOMY TO BE THE
FIFTH LARGEST IN THE WORLD.
ALTHOUGH THIS HAS BEEN GREAT
PROGRESS THERE IS MORE AND MORE
EVIDENCE SHOWING THAT OUR
INVESTMENTS TO FIGHT CLIMATE
CHANGE ARE NOT GOING TO
COMMUNITIES WHERE FUNDING IS
MOST NEEDED. A JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY REPORT AUTHORED BY THE
STAFF FROM THE UCLA CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES FOUND
THAT THE STRUCTURE OF OUR CLAIM
INVESTMENTS IS SKEWED TO
BENEFIT THE MOST AFFLUENT
COMMUNITIES. IN OUR STATE. THIS
HAS COME AT THE EXPENSE OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THEY HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
ABILITY AND RESOURCES TO ACCESS
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND SUCH
INCENTIVES. BERMAN COMMITTEES
ARE BEING LEFT BY THE WAYSIDE
AS OUR STATE ADDRESSES CLIMATE
CHANGE. EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY HELPS
BRIDGE THIS GAP BY IMPLEMENTING
NEW KEY POLICIES RECOMMENDED IN
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S RECENT
REPORT. PUTTING CALIFORNIA ON
THE HIGH ROAD ADOPTING CLIMATE
ACTION PLAN FOR TWENTY THIRTY.
THIS BILL COMES TO YOU AFTER
ENJOYING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
COMING UP THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY WOULD REQUIRE
GIGI R. F. APPLICANTS TO USE
FAIR AND RESPONSIBLE EMPLOYER
STANDARDS TO PROMOTE HIGH
QUALITY JOBS INCLUSIVE.
PROCUREMENT POLICIES TO MAKE
SURE APPLICANTS ARE CONTRACTING
WITH OTHER REASONABLE.
RESPONSIBLE ENTITIES AND
PREVAILING WAGE FOR
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. THIS
BILL WOULD FURTHER PRIORITIZE
APPLICANTS THAT PARTNER WITH
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT TARGET
RESIDENTS UNDER RESOURCE TRIBAL
AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES IN
THE SAME REGION OUT OF THE
PROJECT. THESE PROVISIONS WHICH
ARE JUST A FEW OF THE
RECOMMENDATION PROPOSED BY THE
CW DB'S HI ROAD REPORT. BUT
PRINCIPLES OF EQUITY ON THE
FRONT END OF THE APPLICATION
PROCESS RATHER THAN AN
AFTERTHOUGHT THROUGH THE SET
ASIDES WE CURRENTLY HAVE IN
PLACE. I RESPECTFULLY QUESTION
I BUILT ON A. B. SIX EIGHTY TO
MAKE SURE THE COMMUNITIES WHICH
NEED THESE CLIENT INVESTMENTS
ARE MOST ARE NOT LEFT BEHIND.
THANK YOU FOR THE REMAINDER
CENTERS NEW IDENTIFIED LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESS ON THIS BILL-
HERE TO TESTIFY AS JEREMY SMITH
FROM CALIFORNIA STATE BUILDING
TRADES. OKAY WELCOME- YOU MAY
COULDN'T PROCEED ON. FOOT FOR
UP TO TWO MINUTES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH
CARA BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL APOLOGIZE. IN
ADVANCE TO THE UTHOR INTO THE
COMMITTEE FOR OUR LETTER NOT
BEING IN- WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. OF THIS LEGISLATION-
THIS IS AN EFFORT TO SPEND ON
GO FIRST. YEARS IT TO PUT SOME.
GUIDELINES AROUND THIS G. R. A
FUNDING TO ENSURE THAT. THE
MONEY THAT'S COMING AND BILLION
DOLLARS COMING IN AND GOING OUT
AGAIN- GO TO PUT THE PRODUCE
GOOD JOBS. WITH HIGHER WAGES-
ACTUALLY- PRODUCE MIDDLE CLASS
LIVELIHOODS FOR THE WORKERS IN
THE DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES
BENEFITING. FROM THE G. G. R.
F. WE ARE. HAPPY THAT THEY AS A
MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS
TAKEN ON THIS EFFORT THIS YEAR.
WE THINK IT IS LONG OVERDUE- WE
WOULD OPPOSE ANY EFFORT TO-
HEART OUR ANY PART OF. OF OF
STATUTE THAT DEALS. WITH AN
INDUSTRY THAT GETS FUNDING FROM
GIGI R. F. BECAUSE WE REALLY DO
BELIEVE- WE NEED TO AS YOU ALL
NEED IS THE LEGISLATURE TO PUT-
PUT YOUR FOOT DOWN. AND SAY YOU
KNOW BASICALLY THROUGH THIS
BILL. WE ARE GOING TO ENSURE
THAT WORKERS ARE TAKEN CARE OF-
IN INDUSTRIES THAT RECEIVED
GIGI R. F. THAT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO I THINK TAXPAYERS.
IF YOU ASK THEM WOULD SAY YES
WE WANT OUR MONEY GOING TO-
GOOD GOOD WAGES GOOD JOBS. ARE
TO ENSURE THAT WORKERS- IN
THESE INDUSTRIES ARE NOT-
RECEIVING THEIR HEALTHCARE
RECEIVING BENEFITS. THROUGH
OTHER STATE AGENCIES ARE STATE
PROGRAMS. ONSTAD THEY'RE
GETTING THEM FROM THEIR WAGES
AND BENEFITS- THAT THEY EARN
FROM THEIR JOB. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WERE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY YOU THINK THE
AUTHOR BRING IT FORWARD AND WE-
DRIVE UP THANK. THANK YOU WILL
MOVE NOW TO- SUPPORT POSITIONS
OF PEOPLE WHO WERE PRESENT IN
THE COMMITTEE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE A SUPPORT POSITION ON A.
B. SIX EIGHTY PLEASE COME FORTH.
IN ORDER TO SHALL WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU TO ANYONE
ELSE HERE PRESENT TWO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
CITIES. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ATTEND
CRIMMINS INTERNATIONAL
OPERATING JUNIORS FULL SUPPORT
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU OF
ANYONE ELSE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX EIGHTY. THE
SCENE NONE WILL CHECK THE
SPILLOVER ROOM FOR WITNESSES
OR- IS NO ONE THERE WISHING TO
TESTIFY WILL GO TO THE
MODERATOR ASKED MODERATOR. BUT
PLEASE KEEP UP IS FOR WHEN THIS
IS ONLY BE SUCCEEDING PLEASE
LET US KNOW THE NUMBER
WITNESSES THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
S. B. YOU WERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIX EIGHTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
THEY'RE OFF HERE IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIX EIGHTY. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE TO AT THIS TIME THEN WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEMBERS
GOOD AFTERNOON JAMES DIRECTOR
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL LABORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MEXICO TO
LINE ONE SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER FROM
NIELSEN WORKS WERE ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS IN CALIFORNIA WE
ARE MAINTENANCE AMEND
PRODUCTION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED CONVERSATION BUT THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
WE HAVE NO FOR THIS IMPORTANT
QUEUE AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL
COME BACK CURRENT TO- THE
OPPOSITION SIDE OF THE EQUATION
HERE WE HAVE A LEAD OFFICERS
WITNESSES UNDERSTAND IT MARKS
DIVERSE. UP GOOD AFTERNOON
PLEASE PROCEED EXTRAMARKS
DIVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AND WE
RESPECT WITH RESPECT WE MUST
OPPOSE AB SIX EIGHTY UNLESS
AMENDED. WE ALL SUPPORT STRONG
LABOR STANDARDS FOR STATE
PROGRAMS BUT IF THIS IS CENTER
CORTESE SAID AND SENATE HOUSING
COMMITTEE THE OTHER DAY. THERE
ARE TIMES IN THIS MAKES SENSE
AND TIMES WHEN IT DOESN'T. FOR
TO THE TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROGRAMS FUNDED BY THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
THE BILLS JUST DON'T MAKE
SENSE- IT MOVE FORWARD WILL
HOUSING AND SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM. RECEIVE
20% OF THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND REVENUES AND
ALREADY SERVES DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES- OFTEN IN INLAND
AREAS WHERE WE JUST DON'T HAVE
MUCH OF A UNION WORK FORCE. US
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN STUDY BY
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
MENTIONED THAT WE NEED TO
DOUBLE OR TRIPLE OUR STATE
CONSTRUCTION WORK FORCE TO MEET
OUR FOR WILL HAVE A MEET
HOUSING NEEDS GENERALLY. AND
I'VE HEARD ESTIMATES IS ONLY
ABOUT 20% OF THE YOU CAN.
CURRENT CONSTRUCTION WORK FORCE
IS UNION. SO I PROJECT AND HAVE
A THEY AGREEMENT THE CANNOT A
UNION. WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
PROCEED AT ANY PRICE. AND IN
PLACES WHERE WITH MORE OF A
UNION PRESENCE WILL BE
DIFFICULT TO GET THREE
COMPETITIVE BIDS. FOR HEATING
CONTRACTORS IN WHICH CASE THE
CONTRACTORS WILL HAVE MARKET
POWER. TO SET ANY PRICE. LIKE
FLIES WITH THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM- THAT
BRING SOLAR AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY TO EXISTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE WORK IS
GENERALLY DONE AS PART OF A
MAJOR OVERHAUL OF THE
REDEVELOPMENT A WRITTEN A
REHABILITATION DOESN'T WORK.
AND IF ANYONE SOURCE TRIGGERS
PREVAILING WAGE THE ENTIRE
SCOPE OF WORK MUST BE
PREVAILING WAGE. WHICH RAISES
COSTS ON AVERAGE 13% STATEWIDE
BUT IN THIS CASE HOUSING
PROVIDER SIMPLY WILL PASS ON
THE LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION
PROGRAM FUNDS AS IT WOULD ADD
MORE COST TO THE PROJECT AND
THEY WOULD FOR RECEIVING THE
AMOUNT OF THE GRANT. BEING A
NET NEGATIVE. CALIFORNIA WILL
LOSE THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS AND SUBJECT
RESIDENTS TO HIGHER UTILITY
BILLS AS A AS A RESULT. SO WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE CONSIDERED AMENDMENT
TO EXEMPT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM. AND THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM FROM
THIS BILL THAT LEAVES THE
REMAINDER OF THE BILL AND TAX
AND HELP TO SPEAK NOT ONLY
ACHIEVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
GOALS. FOR GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION GOALS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE-
OPEN IT UP NOW TO ANYONE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO A B. SIX
EIGHTY. PLEASE COME FORWARD. C.
NONE OF WILL CHECK YOUR FULL
ROOM THERE'S NO ONE THERE TO
TESTIFY WILL GO TO THE
MODERATOR ASKED MODERATOR QUEUE
UP ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON
A B. SIX EIGHTY. THANK YOU IF
YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SIX EIGHTY BY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO OF
HERE IN OPPOSITION OF AB SIX
EIGHTY. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE TO
IN Q. WE WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU KNOW WHY IT WOULD BE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING
INTERNATIONALLY AT. THE REMARK
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER STUIVER AND
HER JOB POSITION THANK YOU KNOW.
THANK YOU AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
I WOULD GIVE THEM MY LINE
NUMBER AND AS A REMINDER IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SIX EIGHTY YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND. BUT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
ONE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS RICHARD
MARCUSSEN FOR THE PLUMBING
HEATING COOLING CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
YOUR MODERATOR OF COMPACT TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS CENTER
DRAWS OF. A YESI WOULD- MOVE
THE BILL WHEN OF WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE MISTER CHAIR AND
ALSO WANT TO APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR- I THINK THIS IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT CONNECTION TO MAKE
BETWEEN. OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
NEEDS ESPECIALLY AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE CHANGING THE WORD
DISADVANTAGED UNDER RESOURCE.
IT'S NOT LIKE COMMUNITIES ARE
BORN DISADVANTAGED IS BECAUSE A
DELIBERATE DECISION IS MADE.
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN TO
UNDER RESOURCE NOT PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT'S WHAT CREATES A
DISADVANTAGE IT'S NOT THE OTHER
WAY AROUND- I THINK THE- THE
PART OF BEING UNDER RESOURCE IS
NOT HAVING ACCESS TO GOOD JOBS
GOOD PAYING JOBS. WE HAVE TO
COME TO GRIPS WITH THAT BECAUSE
WE CANNOT DO OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
DUTIES- AND CREATE LOW PAYING
JOBS AND THEN THAT CREATES A
DEMAND FOR MORE AFFORDABLE LOW
INCOME HOUSING THEN THAT. I
MEAN IT'S JUST A TERRIBLE
VICIOUS CYCLE SO I THINK- THIS
IS THIS IS THE DIRECTION OF
HIGHROAD PARTNERSHIPS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT I KNOW IN
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT-
AGENCIES AND GROUPS- WE REALLY
NEED GOOD PAYING JOBS PERIOD
AND I. AGAIN I'M GLAD TO
SUPPORT AND I THANK THE AUTHOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR OF
ANYONE ELSE AT THIS TIME BUT
YES MADAM BUTCHER. SO M. FOR
THE RECORD- AND DISCUSS TO ANY
MY COMMITTEES YOU'RE MORE THAN
WELCOME TO GIVE ME FEEDBACK ON
THIS PART BUT IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT ANY STATE
FUNDED A PROJECT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ANY STATE PROJECT.
TWENTY OF IT ANY C. PROJECT IS
ALREADY UNDER. THE PURVIEW THAT
THEY HAVE TO BE THE EMPLOYEES
HAVE TO BE PAID- PREVAILING
WAGE. ON ANY ANY. I MEAN IT
FROM A LOCAL PERSPECTIVE I IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT ANYTHING
THAT HAS STATE FUNDING. MUST BE
OUR EMPLOYEES MUST BE PAID-
PREVAILING WAGE- I'M GOING TO
IDEA IS GOING TO COME UP AND
ANSWER THEM FOR YOU SO THAT YOU
HAVE A 100% CONCRETE ANSWER HOW
HOWEVER CLEARLY THAT'S NOT THE
CASE BECAUSE WE START TO SIGN.
BUTTON YES THIS GERRY SMITH
ROBERT HALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL YES THAT IS
CORRECT SNATOR. ANY
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT- THE
ESTATE FUNDING OVER A THOUSAND
DOLLARS DOES HAVE TO PAY
PREVAILING WAGE. OKAY SO WITH
THAT IN MIND- AIDS CONTINUES WE
SEE THIS- OPPOSITION TO
BRITAIN'S STATUTE- WHAT I CALL
THEM. IN MY PERSONAL OPINION-
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES WERE
NOT EVERYONE HAS THE ABILITY TO
BID. ON THESE PROJECTS- GIVEN
THE FACT AND WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO PROVIDE A PREVAILING
WAGE JOBS BUT- IT IS MANDATORY
IT'S AN STATURE REDDING
CALIFORNIA THAT ANYBODY THAT
BIDS OR PROVIDES OR OR OR-
BASED ON THESE PROJECTS THAT
PROVIDE YOU JOBS ON STATE.
FUNDED PROJECTS ARE PREVAILING
WAGE SO I HAVE A CONCERN WITH
THIS BILL IN THE SENSE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE- WE'RE LIMITING. YOU
CAN BID FOR THESE JOBS NOT
NECESSARILY- WITH THE FACT THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE PAYING
PREVAILING WAGE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO- BUT MY CONCERN WOULD
BE IN AREAS WHERE. LABOR IS-
LIMITED- YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF. OPPORTUNITIES FOR
DIFFERENT COMPANIES TO COME IN
BED SO THAT THAT THAT MAKES THE
NUMBER OF COMPANIES I CAN BID
ON PROJECTS TO A SMALLER NUMBER
WHICH MEANS THAT THE COST OF.
DOING THAT PROJECT NOT THE FACT
THAT THEY'RE NOT BE FEELING
PREVAILING WAGE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO DO THAT BUT THE COST.
OF THE PROFIT MARGIN WOULD BE
HIGHER. SO THE PUT THE PRICES
WOULD BE MUCH MUCH HIGHER FOR
THESE PROJECTS. I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
SAYING THAT EVEN THOUGH THEY
HAVE TO PAY PREVAILING WAGE
WHICH WOULD BE THE SAME AMOUNT
THAT THE PRIME WHY WOULD THE
PROJECT BE MORE EXPENSIVE IN
YOUR PURVIEW BECAUSE THERE
WOULD BE LESS PEOPLE BIDDING ON
THE PROJECTS SO. BECAUSE
THERE'S LESS PEOPLE BE ABLE TO
BID ON THESE PROJECTS IT COULD
FACILITATE THAT PROFIT MARGIN
TO GO HIGHER- BUT IF YOU OPEN
IT TO ANYONE AND EVERYONE. ON
THE ROCK SHE WOULD BE AN
EFFECTIVE MEANS OF BEATING
PROCESS ON IT TONIGHT I GUESS
MY CONFUSION IS THAT WHY
WOULDN'T ANY OF THEM BE ABLE TO
WORK WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
WHY WOULD ANY OF THEM NOT BE
ALLOWED TO WORK WITH BUILDING
TRADES. NO I'M GOING TO PUT
PRINT ON MY GOAL IS. MY INTENT
IS TO EMPHASIZE THAT I WOULD
LOVE FOR IT TO BE OPEN TO
EVERYONE NOT JUST PARTICULARLY-
IT IS OPEN TO EVERYONE WE'RE
NOT WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT
THERE'S ANYONE THAT CANNOT BE
IT WE'RE JUST SAYING THAT THEY
IT SHOULD BE THROUGH AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM AND-
HAVE WORKED WITH THE- WITH. AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES THAT IS NOT
SAYING THAT ANYONE CAN BID
ANYONE CAN WORK WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES AS A MATTER OF
FACT IN MY WORK ON THIS BILL
TALKING TO THE OPPOSITION.
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHEN THEY
SAY THAT THERE'S AREAS WHERE
THERE'S LACK OF WORKERS. IT IS
ACTUALLY THE JOB OF THE
BUILDING TRADES TO WORK WITH
THESE COMPANIES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY BUILD THAT DROP
FORGED IN ANY AREAS THAT THAT
THAT. THERE AREN'T THE AMPLE
AMOUNT OF WORKERS AND TO GET
FROM THERE. SO THIS DOES LIMIT
WHO CAN BID. AND NOW I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT'S A WAY TO
LOOK AT IT IF YOU WANT TO. BUT
THE REALITY IS IT DOESN'T LET
LIMIT WHO THERE'S NO
LIMITATIONS TO WHO CAN WORK
WITH THE CONSTRUCTION TRADES.
OKAY SO ANYONE FROM ANY
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM CAN
ACTUALLY WORK ON THESE PROJECTS.
YES I GUESS CENTER THERE ARE
UNION AND NONUNION STATE
APPROVED APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS AND ONE OF THE
BEAUTIES ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT
PARTS OF THE PREVAILING WAGE
OTHER THAN- PAYING LIVING WAGES
A MIDDLE CLASS BENEFITS- IT
FIXES THE COST OF LABOR.
EVERYBODY'S GETTING ON THE SAME
PROJECT UNDER THE SAME RULES SO
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE THE SAME
LABOR COSTS WHETHER THEIR UNION
OR NONUNION. OKAY PERFECT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY ANY
ANYTHING ALSO FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. A CITY NINE- LET
ME JUST SEE TO THE OUTER BEFORE
HE CLOSER TO APPRECIATE. YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND ON THE AMENDMENTS
I THINK THE CONCERN YOU FROM
AGREED TO ADDRESS WITH YOU
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES- I
WON'T REPEAT MUCH OF WHAT
SENATOR CROSSIN SAID BUT- I
KNOW THERE WAS CONCERNED EARLY
ON THE NOTICE WITH THIS BILL
BUT IN GENERAL AT TIMES- WILL
USE WRONG INDEX OR INDICATOR
OR- BUT ONE THAT WE HAVEN'T
RECEIVED REACHED THE OUTCOMES
THAT WE LIKE TO SEE- THESE
ISSUES COME UP SO WE APPRECIATE
YOUR COOPERATION AGAIN IN. OF
THE SEVERE OPPORTUNITY CLOSE.
IF YOU BOTH TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU CHAIRED THE CHAIR IN THE-
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE WORK ON
ON THIS BILL WE APPRECIATED AND
WE UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE
THAT NEW VERNACULAR. AND
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS I WOULD HAVE TO
REITERATE THAT WHEN WE SPEAKING
ABOUT WITH THE OPPOSITION WE
DID DO A LOT OF WORK WITH THEM
AND ALSO THAT IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT WE HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL
DISBELIEF. WHY WOULD WE BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND NOT PAY
PEOPLE A PROPER WAGE AND GIVE
THEM THE PROPER BENEFITS THAT
THEY REALLY DO DESERVE. AND
GIVE THEM THE TRAINING THAT
THEY NEED TO HAVE NOT JUST. NOT
JUST TO TAP REAL CAREERS TO
HAVE REAL OPPORTUNITY AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT'S DAY FUNDS
REALLY SHOULD GO TO WITH THAT I
SIMPLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
OKAY THEN THANK YOU CAN AND-
SENATOR ALSO OFFERED A MOTION.
AS WELL AS CONSOLE TO CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS. AMENDED FIRST AMEND AND
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. COURTESY
ON BUT AS THE I OR CHOI BOGUE
NOW THE TROUBLED NOW TO WRESTLE
I THE REST SO I. LAYERED HI
LARRY I NEWMAN HI THURMOND I.
OKAY THE VOTERS FOR THE ONE ON
THE BILLS OUT THANK YOU-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR WOULD BE
NEXT UP ON OUR AGENDA A. B.
TEN
TWENTY THREE. WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN YOU'RE WELCOME TO
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IT'S A
PRIVILEGE TO BE IN FRONT OF YOU
TODAY. TODAY I AM PRESENTING AB
TEN TWENTY THREE WHICH WOULD
ENACT A PENALTY OF A HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER DAY AGAINST ANY.
PUBLIC WORKS CONTRACTOR WHO
FAILED TO SUBMIT ELECTRONIC
CERTIFIED PAYROLL RECORDS ON A
MONTHLY BASIS. AB TEN TWENTY
THREE ALSO PROVIDES A FOURTEEN
DAY GRACE PERIOD WITH EMPLOYERS
TO SUBMIT. ELECTRONIC PAYROLL
PLATONIC CERTIFIED PAYROLLS A
TOOL. USED BY THE STATE TO
ENSURE CONTRACTORS OF PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS ARE PAYING THEIR
WORKERS. THE PREVAILING WAGE IF
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO I WANT TO
STRESS THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS ALREADY REQUIRED. WITH
CONTRACTS AB TEN TWENTY THREE
WOULD SIMPLY PROVIDE
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM TO ENSURE
THE CONTRACT CONTRACTORS ARE
ABIDING BY THE LAW. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
TO THEM THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I UNDERSTAND- WE HAVE TIM
CRIMMINS HERE IS A LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESS. DISCREPANCY MAY
PROCEED. VETERANS OF PEOPLE
FAIRLY STRAIGHT FOR BUILT A
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES SUBMISSION
OF PAYROLL RECORDS NO PENALTY
THIS WOULD- THE INSTITUTE A
PENALTY ON IT SHOULD BE NOTED
ELECTED OF THE AUTHOR SAID
WE'VE TAKEN AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS CONTRACTOR EMPLOYER
CONCERNS BUT ALSO IT SHOULD BE
NOTED GENERALLY THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER ASK FOR LEAD
TRONIC CERTIFIED PAYROLL THAT
OF COURSE EXPEDITES-
INVESTIGATIONS- IN AND- IT
HELPS WITHROW LIMITED RESOURCES
IN THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE SO THEY CAN DO OTHER
INVESTIGATIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH READ THANK YOU. WE'RE NOW
OPEN FOR FOLKS WHO ARE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WE WISH TO
EXPRESS A SUPPORT POSITION ON
THIS BILL. MANUELA SHEA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
JOURNEY SMITH CHEVY HALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO SUPPORT.
THIRTY TWO THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEN NONE. BUT
WILL CHECK THE OVERFLOW ROOM.
WE SEE NO WITNESSES- WILL GO TO
THE MODERATOR NASA MODERATOR-
IF WE HAVE SUPPORT WITNESSES ON
THE TELECOM SERVICES SO PLEASE
KEEP THEM OPEN. WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW HOW MANY THERE ARE. THANK
YOU FOR IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
TWENTY THIRTY MY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AMEND THEIR
AFFAIR IN SUPPORT OF AB. TEN
TWENTY THREE. MAKE SURE WE HAVE
THREE IN Q. WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE OF SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MAP BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THEN WE'LL GO TO
LINE NOW ONE OF SEVENTY TWO.
I'M. I'M SORRY HERE ONE MOMENT.
ONE ONE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN RESOURCES SEVEN MONDAY
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
COUNCIL OF ENGINEERING
COMPANIES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
FOR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE
DO HAVE ONE MORE CUED UP- AS A
REMINDER WE ARE ON A. B. TEN
TWENTY THREE AND SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JAMES DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL LABORS
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTING QUEUE AT THIS TIME
MISTER WITH THE MODERATOR OF
THIS UNDERSTAND THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS- IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION POSITION IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM. M. C. NONE
OTHER SOMEONE IN OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY. SO
COMPACT THE MODERATOR ONCE
AGAIN IN A SMARTER TO QUEUE UP
ANY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY ON A.
B. TEN TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU
HAVE BEEN OPPOSITION OF AB TEN
TWENTY THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN THE ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR ANY OPPOSITION OF AB.
TEN TWENTY THREE. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND- CHECK TO SEE IF
THERE ANY COMMENTS CONCERNS
QUESTIONS OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AS SEEN ON WILL GIVE
AN OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE A CLASS
ARRIVAL THANK YOU SIR OKAY.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION- IS OUR MOTION ON
THIS BILL. THE MOVE- SENATOR
OCHO OF BOOKS ARE PUBLISHER IN
WILL MOVE TO THE CONSULTANT
ALAN S. CONSOLE TO TAKE THE
ROLE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COURTESY HI BUT DOES THE I. R.
CHOI BOGUE HI FOR TROUBLED BY
THE ADDRESS SO. WRESTLE I'D
LAYERED HI LARRY I NEWMAN HI
NEWMAN AYE. YOUR AVAILABLE THE
PASSAGE UNANIMOUSLY TO BILLS
OUT THANK YOU. FOR NEXT UP IS
SB SIX TWENTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA. YOU ARE
HERE WONDERFUL. WELCOME AND I
THINK WE'RE READY FOR YOU TO
STEP UP AND PRESENT IF YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS I WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING V. COMMITTEE
STAFFER THE ANALYSIS AND- WE
WILL BE ACCEPTING D. COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AB SIX TO EIGHT
WOULD EXPAND THE BREAKING
BARRIERS- OPPORTUNITIES- FOR
ASSISTING ADDITIONAL
INDIVIDUALS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
OBTAINING. UP PROGRAMS AND
SUPPORT SERVICES AT THAT WOULD
BE MEANINGFUL TO OBTAINING- JOB
OPPORTUNITIES DURING THIS-
DIFFICULT TIME POST- COVERT-
ERA. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE DIDN'T ATTACK TO
JUST HIGHLIGHT THAT IN THE
BUDGET. THAT THAT WE WILL BE A
DELIBERATING DEBATING IN A FEW
HOURS- THERE WILL BE AN
ALLOCATION OF THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO FUND THIS
INITIATIVE. SO IT'S EXCITING TO
SEE THAT- THIS- PROGRAM WITH
THE GROUND RUNNING- IMMEDIATELY
UPON YOUR- CONSIDERATION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
OKAY THANK YOU FOR SHARING THAT
WITH US SOON I UNDERSTAND THAT-
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS. WITNESSES
ARE PRESENT MARK FILL PART.
ACTUALLY CALLING ON THE TOLL
CORPUSCLE IN MEGAN ORTIZ ALSO
ON THE. COAST TELECONFERENCE
LINE- MISTER PHIL PER IF YOU
YOU MAY BE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS- MY
NAME IS MARK SO FAR I'M A
MANAGING DIRECTOR OF POLICY
LINK ALSO SUPPORT THE
COORDINATION OF THE ALLIANCE OF
BOYS AND OF COLOR. THE ALLIANCE
IS A NETWORK OF OVER TWO
HUNDRED GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATIONS ADVANCING RACE
AND GENDER JUSTICE BY
TRANSFORMING SYSTEMS THAT BELL
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR THEIR
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES. AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
BREAKING BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT
INITIATIVE TO ASSIST
INDIVIDUALS WHO FACE MULTIPLE
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT. WITH
SUPPORT TO SUCCESSFULLY
PARTICIPATE IN TRAINING
APPRENTICESHIP AND GOOD JOB
OPPORTUNITIES. POLICY LINK IN
THEIR LINES OF BOYS AND THE
COLOR COSPONSORED THAT BILL
WHICH CREATED THE INITIATIVE
AND THAT WAS. MAYBE ELEVEN
ELEVEN WHICH WAS ALSO OFFERED
BY MR GARCIA. SB SIX TO EIGHT
IS THE RENEWAL AND EXPANSION OF
BACKGROUND PROGRAM. SPONSORS
INCLUDE THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER CROP ORGANIZATION THE
ALLIANCE OF BOYS AND THE COLOR
AND POLICY. SB SIX AND THE NEXT
UPON. THE BREAKING BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT INITIATIVE BY
REFOCUSING THE PROGRAM TO
CENTER RACIAL EQUITY IN THE
LABOR FORCE AND SOCIAL ECONOMIC
JUSTICE AS A PRIORITY.
EXPANDING ACCESS AND
ELIGIBILITY FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO SUPPLY
TRAINING. AND SUPPORT SERVICES
AND CREATING GREATER
OPPORTUNITIES TO SHAPE THE
PROGRAM BY ESTABLISHING A
STAKEHOLDER WORKING GROUP OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE OF C. W. D. B.
WHICH INCLUDES COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND LABOR. AND
ALSO OUTLINES REQUIREMENTS FOR
OUTREACH TO SMALLER CBO'S TO
ENSURE AWARENESS AND ULTIMATELY
GROW MORE DIVERSE POOL OF
APPLICANTS CONNECTED TO THE
TARGET POPULATION STIPULATED IN
THE BILL. ANDFINALLY EXPANDS
THE LIST OF TARGET POPULATIONS
TO INCLUDE THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
THE BILL PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY
WITH OVERWHELMING SUPPORT UFCW
RAISE SOME CONCERNS WHICH WERE
ADDRESSED AND AMENDMENTS
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE LAST
WEEK. WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
OPPOSITION HAS BEEN REMOVED. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR IPHONE
ON THIS MEASURE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. OKAY THANK
YOU MEGAN ORTIZ IF YOU'RE HERE
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- AGAIN MY NAME IS MEGAN
ARE IF YOU CAN THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE INSTITUTE OF
POPULAR EDUCATION OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA YOU'VE GOT SCOTT.
WHEREAS YOU LARGEST WORKERS
THAT ARE NONPROFIT IN THE STATE
THE EXPLICATION- SERVING AND
ADVOCATING WITH THOUSANDS OF
THE LABORS AND DOMESTIC WORKERS
PREDOMINANTLY PEOPLE OF COLOR
IN MY CURRENT. HI MY- AGE ARE
WORKER MEMBERS ARE OFTEN AN
ELIGIBLE BECAUSE OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS- FROM ACCESS
THE STATE AND FEDERAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM. SO IT
FALLS ON ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS
OUR OWN- TO REALLY CREATE
HARLOW WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
SYSTEM PROVIDING NOT EDUCATION
ON THE JOB TRAINING. AND
SUPPORT OF SERVICES TO THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS EXCLUDED FROM
TRADITIONAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM- YOU KNOW
THE BREAKING BARRIERS. THE
POINT AT LEAST WAS REALLY TO US
BECAUSE THE MEANT I ARE OUR OUR-
I REMEMBER WOULD HAVE ACCESS.
CAN BE RECTIFIED THE HARD THE
WORK FOR ABOUT. SYSTEM IN THE-
YOU KNOW IT'S AND FOR WERE
CENTER TO THAT GOD REALLY BEAT
THE- BY THE STATE LABOR
DEVELOPMENT- BUT THE ORIGINAL
PROGRAM REALLY GET PRISON
CHALLENGES. IN THE UPPER- FOR
THE CRY. WAS SOMEWHAT UNCLEAR
AND THERE REALLY WASN'T TOO
TECHNICAL IS FOR SMALLER THE
OPRAH HOURS AND AFTER THE APT
PROCESS. AB THREE TO EIGHT
LIVES THAT OR- LIKE OUR ENOUGH.
WORK CENTERS AND ARE MEMBERS
WITH THE PHONE BACK. AS PART OF
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM-
AND REALLY BE ABLE TO ACT THAT
COULD FUNDING- THIS. THAT
PROPOSED IN THE BILL- IT'S AB
OVER. AT THE PPO REALLY CAN LET.
BURKE HE JUST THAT REACHED THE
TO ENSURE THAT SMALLER OR-
REALLY. THE WORK ABOUT SYSTEM
WITH THE AT RACIAL EQUITY FROM
THIS SO CRITICAL RIGHT NOW- THE
AT. A LOCKED NO IT BE
IMMIGRANTS WHO COMMITTED THE
WORD DISPROPORTIONATELY DOUBLE.
BY THEIR- REALLY THE NEED TO BE
IN IN THE- AS IT CAN. HOPE
YOU'RE- THE EXAMPLE IT IS TO
THE RIGHT OF THE COUNTRY SIX
EIGHT ONE WAY TO MAKE THAT
POSSIBLE YEAH. I THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU- WE'RE GOING TO
ASK THE SENATE IN COMMITTEE
ROOM WHICH IS TO EXPRESS THE
SOME. POSITION ON THIS. FOR PUT
PROCEED SHARE MEMBERS OF THE ON
PRO ON THE OF THE- WORK FOR US.
REPRESENTING THE FOR FIVE LOCAL
WORK ORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARDS
AROUND THE STATE WE WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA.
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU. YOUR
STAFF AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
ENGAGING. IN THIS ISSUE AND
HELPING RESOLVE SOME OF THE
DIFFERENCES- WE WANT TO ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
MISTER PRIME. IT IS THE ONE ARE
YOU REALLY THIS IS A POINT IN
TIME FOR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PLEASE PROCEED. THIS IS SHERIN
MEMBERS MANUELA SHEA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION PLEASE REMEMBER
OPPOSITION WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS FOR
WORKING WITH US TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
AT YOUR PRESENT WISHES TO
SUPPORT BUT EXPRESSED A SUPPORT
POSITION. THE CITY NONE OF
WILL. CHECK THE OVERFLOW ROOM
AGAIN- THERE NO WITH THIS IS
THERE WELCOME BACK TO THE
MODERATOR IN S. THE MODERATOR.
ON A. B. SIX TWENTY EIGHT TO
PLEASE QUEUE UP IN THE SUPPORT.
OF THE TESTIMONY HERE PLEASE
LET US KNOW THE NUMBER. THANK
YOU IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIX TWENTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
THERE APPEARED SUPPORT OF AB.
SIX TWENTY EIGHT. MISTER CHAIR.
WE HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN IN KILL
THE LEARNING QUEUE THE NEW
RECORD OKAY WELL WE'LL HAVE A
LIMIT OF TEN MINUTES SO THEY'RE
ALL GOING TO HAVE TO BE VERY
QUICK HERE THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU AND WE WILL GO TO A
LINE OF ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS GENEVIEVE FLORES HARO
ELEVEN OCT IN CALIFORNIA AND
I'M REPORT MAJOR FORTY
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE NETWORK. HI IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY SIX TWENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO
LINE OF ONE AND SIXTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS BENEFITTED ON POLICY
AND COMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATE
WITH THE STATE GOING TO CANNOT
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING PROJECT
AND I'M PART OF THE CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
NETWORK. I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIX TO EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO
LINE OF ONE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS THAT A LITTLE BIT AND I LIVE
IN LOS ANGELES AND I AM WITH
EITHER CENTERS WOMEN'S CENTER
AND I AM A PART OF THE RGV
ENTITY CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE NECKER AND I
AM CALLING TO URGE. IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX TO
EIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND NEXT WE WILL GO TO A LINE
OF TO ALL ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CAN YOU REMEMBER PREFERRED
DOCTOR ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER
FOR EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
AND CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT OF AB
EXTREMELY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NXR GO TO LINE A ONE EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ERIC MORE
METROPOLITAN LINCOLN THE A
MONSTER BUT THE MEN OF COLOR WE
ARE CO SPONSORS AND INSTRUCT
THE COURT. EIGHTY SIX TO EIGHT.
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT A LINE OF
TWO EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ON A BIKE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND CHILD
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF TWO FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS PATTY W.
B. M. AND I'M WITH CENTRAL
VALLEY IMMIGRANT POPULATION
COOPERATIVE AND I'M CALLING AND
THE STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SIX
TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE OF TWO OH FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M HEADING NAM I
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES AND I'M
WITH UNITED LA A NONPROFIT
FOCUSED ON CRADLE TO CAREER
EDUCATION REFORM CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SIX TO
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
OVER THE LINE OF ONE NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS HELENA HODA AND I'M
WITH OAKLAND ORGANIZATION OF
SAFE PLACE I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SIX TWENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU MEXICO TO LINE A ONE EIGHTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS GINA CALL AND I'M WITH
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER WHERE COSPONSORED.
EIGHTY SIX TWENTY AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT OF A LOT OF TWO NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS TALKING ABOUT I LIVE IN SAN
JOSE CALIFORNIA I AM WITH
CENTER FOR EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
I AM CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
AT EIGHTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF TWO
TWENTY A LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS AQI LINARES BROWN OF
BRICKS THAT I LIVED IN LOS
ANGELES AND I AM WITH THE
FILIPINO WORKER CENTER. IN
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND EIGHTY SIX
YOU EIGHT. THANK YOU MEXICO TO
LINE OF TWO SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE TO SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEXT OVER THE
LINE OF ONE NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
WE ARE STANSBURY WITH JANICE
YOU CENTER AND CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
NETWORK AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF. AB. SIX
TWENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU AN
EXTRA GO TO LINE A ONE NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS ANNE CAN I LIVE IN LOS
ANGELES AND I AM WHAT KOREAN
AMERICAN FAMILY SERVICES. AND I
AM PART OF COCOA CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
NOT BARK I AM CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIX TWENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE OF TWO FIFTEEN YEAR LINE
OF THE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MILAN MORRIS I LIVE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I'M WITH MY
SISTERS HOUSE. ALSO PART OF THE
COUNTRY FOR THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE NETWORK AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIX TWENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND ONE
MOMENT SIR- MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. CORRECT.
AND AGAIN WE'RE AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF AB IS SIX TWENTY
EIGHT ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE
WILL GO TO THE LINE OF- TO
TWELVE. TO TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS A MESSAGE
OF OUR GREAT PRESENTING CAL
GRANT COALITION CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHTY SIX
TO EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M AS CHAIR WE HAVE ONE MORE
IN Q. AND THAT'S GONNA GO TO
LINE OF- TO TWENTY ONE. NINE
TWO TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS KEN OLIVER
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE CROP
ORGANIZATION WE ARE COSPONSORED
THE BABY SIX TWENTY ONE AND ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU FOR THE TENDER WE WILL COME
BACK TO- THE OPPOSITION SIDE
AND WE HAVE THE LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES OR ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO TAKE IN OPPOSE POSITION.
WHO'S HERE PRESENT IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. SEEN NONE OF
WILL CHECK THE OVERFLOW ROOM
FOR WITNESSES. THERE ARE STILL
NO AMERICAN WILL CONTACT THE
MODERATOR AND ASKED THE
MODERATOR QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES- THAT MAY
BE ON THE TELECONFERENCE WINE.
IN AGAIN PLEASE LET US KNOW THE
NUMBER THANK YOU. FOR COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION TO A. B. SIX
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE ZERO. ONE ONE HUNDRED
NINETY TWO YEAR MY COULD OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS MY
NAME AFTER THE GREAT WALL WITH
UFCW WESTERN STATE COUNCIL I
USED TO W. IS NO LONGER AYE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WE
ACTIVATE THE PERMITTED AT
PUBLIC RECOMMENDED POSITION I
THINK THE COMMITTEE THAT
PROMPTED IN THE AUTHOR. BEING
WILLING TO WORK WITH US ON
LANGUAGE AND THAT WE BELIEVE
ADDRESSES- ALL OF OUR CONCERNS
AND FELT IT WANTED TO THINK
THAT COMMITTEE THE FACT THAT I
AM THE AUTHOR AND THE FOUNDERS
AND ARE NOT MUTUAL ON THE
PROPOSED WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT
WE WERE WORKING. AND I CALL
ORGANIZATIONS AND SO- ALL OF
OUR- THANK YOU WE UNDERSTAND
THAT WE DO THANK YOU. MODERATE
INVESTOR THERE ARE NO THERE ARE
NO COMMENT AT THIS TIME OR
THANK YOU WILL BACK TO
COMMITTEE- CONCERNS COMMENTS
BUT COMMITTEE MEMBER SENATOR
ALSO. I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR- FOR RAISING THE ISSUE
OF HOW DO WE GET TO A
COMMUNITIES THAT FIND IT HARDER
TO ACCESS THE RESOURCES
ESPECIALLY FOR TRAINING BUT ON
NOT JUST THE TRAINING HOW DO
YOU ACTUALLY GET A GOOD JOB
AFTER YOU GET THE TRAINING- I
WORKED FOR MANY YEARS TO BUILD
FROM SCRATCH A TRAINING PROGRAM
IN THE- HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY- I
KNOW HOW HARD IT IS. TO REACH
ARE OF VARIOUS COMMUNITIES BUT
I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT THE
HOSPITALITY TRAINING ACADEMY
NOW OFFERS OF THE KIND OF
TRAINING THAT THROUGH
COLLECTIVEBARGAINING GET SOME
ACTUAL JOB THE YOU KNOW THAT
THEY COULD BENEFIT FROM ALL
THAT TRAINING SO. THANK YOU FOR.
PULLING PEOPLE TOGETHER OF THAT
MIGHT NOT WORK TOGETHER BUT
THAT CAN AND SHOULD SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- YOUR SENATOR-
ANY OTHER QUOTES CLOSER
QUESTIONS CONCERNS- SEEN NONE
OF GIVEN OPPORTUNITY CLOSE- IN
AND BEFORE YOU DO LET ME THANK
YOU FOR WORKING FOR WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THE IMMENSE AND-
FOR YOUR ACCEPTANCE THERE-
THANK YOU SO MUCH. A DISSECTED
GOOD THANK YOU COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR BRINGING FORWARD THESE
AMENDMENTS AND STUFF FOR THE
STAKEHOLDERS OF WILLINGNESS. TO
WORK WITH WITH OUR OFFICE SO
WITH THAT- RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
RIVAL. THANK YOU. AND- WE WOULD
BE LOKING FOR A MOTION ON
FIFTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT. THERE
IS A MOTION FROM SENATOR ALERT
PLUS CONSOLE MCCALL ROLE PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
BE RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COURTESY HI FOR
DOES THE AYE ULTRABOOK AYE THE
TROUBLED ADDRESS SO. RUSSELL I
LAYERED HI LARRY I NEWMAN.
NEWMAN I REQUEST UNANIMOUS WITH
THE BILLS OUT THANK YOU. NEXT
UP FOR THIS COMMITTEE WOULD BE
AB TWO SEVENTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA IS HERE- WELCOME WE'RE
JUST GETTING A PODIUM READY FOR
YOU HERE. UNDER WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND- STILL COPE WITH
CIRCUMSTANCES SO PLEASE SIR
COME ON UP NOW THAT IT'S READY
AND HE MAYES BEGIN YOUR
PRESENTATION WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TODAY PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO SEVENTY FIVE. THANK
YOU TO YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALL THEIR HARD WORK. AND
WORKING WITH A SPONSOR- TAKEN
THE FOLLOWING AMENDMENTS. FIRST
THE FIRST ONE CLARIFIES THE
PROBATIONARY PERIOD ONLY
APPLIES TO DISPATCHED EMPLOYEES
BY PEACE OFFICER OR PUBLIC
SAFETY CERTIFIED DISPATCH
CENTER. THE SECOND IS A
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT THAT
PARALLELS THE K. TWELVE MERIT
DISTRICT IN AB FOUR EIGHTY SIX.
EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE WOULD
REDUCE THE MAXIMUM PROBATIONARY
PERIOD FOR ALL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
WORKING IN A NON MERIT DISTRICT
FOR ONE YEAR FROM ONE YEAR TO
SIX MONTHS OR A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY DAYS OF PAID SERVICE
WHICHEVER IS LONGER. IN NON
MERIT DISTRICTS CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES HAVE A PROBATIONARY
PERIOD MAXIMUM OF ONE YEAR.
WHAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CLASSIFIED PLEASE. FORGET IN
MERRITT DISTRICTS ONLY HAVE A
PROBATIONARY PERIOD MAXIMUM OF
SIX MONTHS. THE PRIMARY PURPOSE
OF PROBATIONARY PERIODS FOR
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES IS
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE
EMPLOYEES ARE ABLE TO PERFORM
THE DUTIES OF THEIR POSITION TO
THE SATISFACTION OF THE
EMPLOYER BEFORE GAINING
PERMANENT STATUS INCLUDING DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS. AS THE
PERFORMANCE EVALUATION PROP IS
PROCESSES IS PROPERLY UTILIZE A
SIX MONTH PROBATIONARY PERIOD
PROVIDES MORE THAN ENOUGH TIME
FOR THE MANAGEMENT TO DETERMINE
WHETHER AN EMPLOYEE HAS MET
THEIR STANDARDS. THREE IN
PARITY TO THE NON MERIT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
WILL NOT COMPROMISE THE QUALITY
OF THE WORK PERFORMED. TWO
YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED A. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY
THREE. DUES THE PROBATIONARY
PERIOD FOR K. TWELVE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES. WORKING IN NON MERIT
DISTRICTS FROM ONE YEAR TO SIX
MONTH IN ALIGNMENT WITH K.
TWELVE CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
WORKING IN AMERICA DISTRICTS.
IN A VIRTUALLY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
WORKING AT NON MERIT DISTRICTS
WERE LEFT OUT. AB TWO SEVENTY
FIVE IS CO SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AFL-CIO HERE TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE BILL
IS ON LOWER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
AND ON THE LINE IS LIBBY
SCIENTISTS WITH BESSIE I YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL GO
AHEAD AND CALL AND SONG LORE OF
THE LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS
WELCOME. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SOMEWHERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION- AS MR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF. MEDINA STATED WE ARE
AT THE SPONSORS OF AB TWO
SEVENTY FIVE. EIGHTY TWO
SEVENTY FIVE IS A CLEAN A BILL
THAT PROVIDES PARITY FOR OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES WHO WORK IN NON MERIT
DISTRICT. AND YOU MIGHT HEAR
FROM THE OPPOSITION AND THEY
MIGHT SAY THAT SIX MONTHS IS
INSUFFICIENT TIME TO FULLY
EVALUATE AN EMPLOYEE- BUT WE
DISAGREE. IF SIX MONTHS IS-SUFFICIENT IN K. TWELVE IS SIX
MONTHS IS SUFFICIENT IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE MEERUT
DISTRICT NOW WHY IS IT
INSUFFICIENT AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE NOT MERIT DISTRICT-
WHAT IS DIFFERENT ABOUT THIS
SUB GROUP THAT- DOES NOT MERIT
THE SIX MONTHS- PROBATION
PERIOD AS WELL. BESIDES OUR
POLICE CLASSIFICATION- IN WHICH
WE TOOK A MAN MADE. A TO
ADDRESS AND DATE MEET D. E. ARE
GOVERNED BY THE COMMISSION ON A
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING OR POST REGULATIONS-
BUT ALL OF OUR OTHER CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES HAPPY SIX MONTH
PROBATION PERIOD- THE OTHER. OF
THE- THE OTHER ARGUMENT YOU.
MAKE HERE IS THAT. SHE SHOULD
BE COLLECT FAR. BUT WE ARE
RIGHT KNOW THAT PROBATION IS
COVER BASED- AGAIN ALL OF OUR
OTHER CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES GET
SIX MONTHS AND SO WE DON'T
THINK THAT THIS SUBGROUP I
SHOULD BE ANY DIFFERENT- THE
ONLY REASON WHY. THEY HAVEN'T
OR THEY DON'T HAVE IT ALREADY
IS BECAUSE WE INADVERTENTLY
LEFT HIM OUT OF. AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY THREE TWO YEARS AGO SO
TODAY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE TO
CORRECT THIS OVERSIGHT AND
PROVIDE PARITY FOR OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES IN DOT MATRIX THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE AND WILL BE SEARCHES IF
YOU'RE ON THE COASTAL CONVERTS
WINDBOT PROCEED. BUT AFTER MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WOULD BE SANTA
ON THE UP OF AT. CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE THE BILL
SIMPLY INSERT THAT SIMILARLY
SITUATED EMPLOYEES ARE TREATED
SIMILARLY FOR PURPOSES OF
PROBATIONARY EMPLOYMENT
PERIODS. THERE IS NO SOUND
PUBLIC POLICY REASONS REQUIRE
THE CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES AND
NON MERIT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS BE SUBJECTED TO A
PROBATIONARY PERIOD DOUBLE OF
THAT OF THEIR COUNTERPARTS IN
MERRICK COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. AND DOUBLE THAT OF
THEIR COUNTERPARTS IN NON MERIT
K. TO TWELVE DISTRICT. REALLY
NO EMPLOYMENT REASON EITHER THE
SIX MONTHS OF PLENTY OF TIME TO
ASCERTAIN WHETHER A
PROBATIONARY EMPLOYEE MEET THE
STANDARDS REQUIRED OF THE
POSITION. IN FACT IT SIX MONTHS
IS NOT ENOUGH TIME THE PROBLEM
REALLY LIES WITH THE EMPLOYERS
PROBATIONARY STRUCTURE AND
TRAINING PROTOCOLS NOT THE
PROBATIONARY CANDOR THAT.
FURTHER WILL NOT TAKE THE
MISSPELLED IMPOSES OVERLY
BURDENSOME REQUIREMENTS ON THE
AFFECTED EMPLOYERS THE EXISTING
TWELVE MONTH PROBATIONARY
PERIOD IT IS OVERLY BURDENSOME
AND UNFAIR TO PROBATIONARY
EMPLOYEES WHO MUST NEEDLESSLY
WAIT AN ADDITIONAL SIX MONTHS.
AND PROBATIONARY PURGATORY TO
FIND OUT WHETHER THEIR
EMPLOYMENT WILL BE PERMANENT OR
NOT. WE REQUEST. YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY THANK
YOU- WE'RE GOING TO COME TO THE
CA ROOM. AND ASK FOR FOLKS STEP
WHO WISH TO TAKE A SUPER
POSITION ON THIS BILL. THE
TEACHER MEMBERS MICHAEL YOUNG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS AND SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHEN MEMBERS
MELODY SHE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOHN RUN AND
I'M WITH THE UC AFT THE UNION
THAT REPRESENTS LIBRARIES
LECTURES DID WAS A CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WISHING TO TAKE A SUPPORT
POSITION. LET'S SEE NONE. WILL
CHECK YOUR FULL ROOM- NOBODY
THERE. WILL MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR. IN S.
FOR ANYONE ON THE TOLL KERMIT'S
ONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. RECOMMEND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. AND MISTER CHAIR LOOKS
LIKE WE HAVE THREE PEOPLE
QUEUING UP TO- MY COMMENT LINE
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY YEAR MIKE IS
UP AND. MCIVER PRESIDENT OF UCF
TEAM STRONG SUPPORT. AND NEXT
WE GO TO LINE TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE LINE TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE OR MY COULD OPEN.
EXACTLY MY NAME'S AFTER MARCATO
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EDUCATION STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU. AN
ONLINE TWO HUNDRED SEVEN. COOL
QUERY WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES CALLING IN
SUPPORT. AND MISTER KERR THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME OKAY THANK MODERATOR ROOM
THERE IS NO LEGAL OPPOSITION
WITNESSES NOTIFIED THE
COMMITTEE OF WISHING TO SPEAK
CIVIL ASKER'S ANYONE HERE WHO.
WISHES TO TAKE IT OPPOSITION
POSITION ON THIS BILL SO STEP
FORWARD PLEASE. C. NONE ON
THURS NO ONE IN YOUR FOR ROOM
IT WOULD COME BACK TO OUR
MODERATOR THIS MONITOR CHECK
TELECONFERENCE LINE. FOR ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO SEVEN
FIVE. FOR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO A B. TWO SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THIS
TIME OKAY THANK YOU MODERATOR
APPRECIATE THAT WILL COME BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE AND SEE IF
THERE'S QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS NO SEE NONE OF THEM-
OKAY WELL THANK YOU. THERE'S A
MOTION BY SENATOR ALSO WILL GO
TO THE CONSULTANT FOR THE ROLL
CALL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. COURTESY HI OR DOES
THE AYE OR TROUBLE. WRESTLE THE
REST OF I LAYERED AYE LAYERED
AYE NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE. WE HAVE
A FOUR TO ONE VOTE AND THE BILL
IS UP THANK YOU. OKAY WE'RE
GONNA GO TO AB SIX FORTY THREES
EIGHT OF THEM LISTED HERE ON
OUR AGENDA AND IT IS A SEVEN
MEMBER RAMOS. SOME MEMBER
WELCOME IS COME ON UP FORGET
EVERYTHING ALL CLEANED UP FOR
YOU UP THERE. YOU MAY BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN-
MEMBERS- AB SIX FOUR THREE
REQUIRES A SCHOOL OR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY. TO CONTACT
LOCAL APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
PRECEDING A COLLEGE OR A CAREER
FAIR. ENSURING THAT STUDENTS
ARE MADE AWARE OF AND HAVE
ACCESS TO LOCAL APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS IN THEIR AREA. RUSSIA
PROGRAMS SERVE A VARIETY OF
IMPORTANT PURPOSES BY BOTH
EXPANDING THE SKILLED WORKFORCE
M. PROVIDING APPRENTICES-
COMPETITIVELY WAGER COMPETITIVE
WAGES CAN. EARN AS YOU LEARN
MODEL HAS PROVEN EFFECTIVE IN
PROVIDING ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITY TO THE JOB MARKET
FOR ALL WORKERS. IT IS CRITICAL
THAT WE ENSURE OUR STUDENTS AND
YOU. HAVE EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
AVAIL THEMSELVES OF THESE
PROGRAMS IF THEY CHOOSE ED A
CAMPUS CAREER FAIRS ARE AMONG
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
INTRODUCTION THAT OUR STUDENTS
GET. TO THE VAST POSSIBILITIES
OF LIFE AFTER GRADUATION. WE
MUST ENSURE TRADE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS ARE
PRESENTED AS AN OPTION AND THIS
BILL WILL ACCOMPLISH THAT.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL IS SCOTT WELCH
REPRESENTING A BROAD COALITION
OF LABOR ORGANIZATIONS. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN
THE WE WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE
TO THE LEAD SPORT WITNESS SCOTT
WHICH- TESTIFIED IN PERSON AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THIS MISTER
WATCHER. MAYBE NOT. I WOULD
CHECK TO MAKE SURE MISTER WHICH
IS AN ON THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE THAT WASN'T THE PLAN
BUT WE WILL. ASK. WE DO WE DO
NOT SHOW THAT SCOTT WHICH HAS
CONNECTED. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU- WE WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE
ON AND- ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WISHES TO
TAKE A SUPPORT POSITION ON THIS
BILL THIS IS SB SIX FORTY
THREE. C. KNOWN COME FORWARD
THE MODERATOR I'M SORRY LET ME
CHECK YOUR FULL ROOM I GOT OFF
MY KID ANSWER THERE'S NO ONE IN
THE OVERFLOW ROOM A MODERATOR
IF YOU CAN QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT
WHEN THIS IS WHO ARE ON THE
TABLE CONVERTS LINE THAT WOULD
BE GREAT AT THIS TIME. PLEASE
LET US KNOW THE NUMBER. AS FAR
COMMENTED IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
FORTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. RECOMMEND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO. AND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH AT THIS TIME OKAY WOMB
NOTE THAT THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS. IDENTIFIED
IN WILL ASK THERE'S ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO TAKE IN OPPOSITION
POSITION ON THIS BILL IN THE
ROOM AGAINST AB SIX FORTY
THREE. UNKNOWN IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM STEPPING FORWARD WILL
CHECK YOUR FULL ROOM THERE'S NO
ONE THERE TO STEP FORWARD AND
WE'LL GO TO MODERNISE MODERATOR
TO QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION.
WITNESSES ON A. B. SIX FORTY
THREE PLEASE. OR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. SIX FORTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. NOT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
SEVEN ZERO. BAND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK
YOU WELCOME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS SOME I
WILL CHECK TO MY RIGHT AND TO
MY LEFT- SEEN NINE- WE'RE GOING
TO ASK THE AUTHOR. OF THE
PEOPLE I CAN HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY CLOSE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL OKAY. IT
SENATORS MOVE THE BILL ANALYST
CONSULTANT CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COURTESY ALL
RIGHT BUT DOES THE I OR
TROUBLED. BUT TROUBLED I DO
WRESTLE. THE RUSSELL I'D
LAYERED HI. I NEWMAN. NEWMAN
AYE THIRTY THIRTY UNANIMOUS
VOTE- IN FAVOR OF THE BILLS OUT
THANK YOU. AB SEVEN IS UP NEXT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ. WE
ARE WITH SOME RODRIGUEZ BACK IN
THE ROOM UNTIL. WE DID EARLIER.
WHAT WE RECESS I'M TOLD THAT
TURNED THE ASSEMBLY SO IN THE
MIDDLE OF FOUR SESSIONS OF THE
REMAINING TWO AUTHORS BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A FIVE BILLS
BUT ONLY TO AUTHORS REPRESENT
THOSE FIVE BILLS AND- THEY ARE
IN ROUTE. IS CERTAINLY SO
THAT'S THE PLAN SO WHEN WE
RECESS- UNTIL FOR. TWENTY EIGHT
CONSISTENT MINUTES- IT SHOULD
BE MORE THAN GENEROUS. THE
SKIPPER REBODIED CHEST
STRUCTURE LEGS HAS BEEN A LONG
MEDIAN ALREADY VERY. OKAY THANK
YOU BUT WE WILL START AT FOUR
TWENTY PLEASE. ASSUME AN AUTHOR.
I KNOW WE HAVE SOME RODRIGUEZ
WHO THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
TO FURTHER. INTERESTING DAYS OF
TRYING TO KEEP TOUR OR SEQUENCE
INDIGENOUS SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COOPERATION AB SEVEN IS
NEXT UP ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND-
YOU'RE WELCOME TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY AND I
KNOW THOSE OF US. WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM ESTABLISHED HERE TODAY
IN THE CENTERS WILL BE WALKING
BACK IN MOMENTARILY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
AS YOU WHERE THEY'RE SHORT I'M
SORRY WRONG BILL CIRCLE BACK TO
YOU SO. YOU JUST MERGE THEM ALL
IN ONE SOLUTION. JUST KIDDING.
FOR THOSE FEW WORLD LISTENING
ASSEMBLY RODRIGUEZ HAS FOR
BILLS SO WE WILL HEAR
CONSECUTIVELY AB SEVENTY THREE
SIXTY FOUR EIGHTY SIX FIFTEEN
AND AB ELEVEN OH FIVE SO GIVE
HIM A CHANCE TO GET COLUSA
SEQUENCE IN ORDER. IS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS COME BACK IN FROM THE
RECESS. COMMISSION MEMBERS. AB
SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE PRIVATE
SECTOR MARC MOVED UPON BY
NUMBER AND SHE NUMBERS AND- TO
MAKE MORE TO THREAT FOR GEAR
READ AVAILABLE WORST TO MY
CALLS. R. FOR GAS FOR A GROUP.
THANK YOU SO ANY OF SUPPORT
WITH PHIL UP T. OR PETTY
PATTILLO GUESS HE CAN NOTICE
KNOW- IT IS TO KEEP. ALL RIGHT
TO YOUR WELCOME TO GO AHEAD AND
COMMENCE YOUR TEST WERE ON TO.
PER WITNESS. I THINK I'M
GETTING ON TO THE THANK YOU
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MY
NAME AGAIN IS BILL PETITE AND I
AM- THE NATIONAL DIRECTOR OF
THE INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF EMTS AND PARAMEDICS IN MY
JOB I REPRESENT OVER THREE
THOUSAND EMS PROFESSIONALS IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY. AND ON THEIR
BEHALF I ASSERT OUR SUPPORT FOR
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY SUBMITTED
BY THE HONORABLE FREDDIE
RODRIGUEZ. FIFTY IDPS FIRM
OPINION THAT EIGHTY SEVEN TAKES
CRITICAL STEPS TOWARDS
IMPROVING WORKPLACE AFTER FIFTY
FOUR AND ROTECTING EMS
PROFESSIONALS IN THE FIELD AS
AN ORGANIZATION BY AND FOR
FIRST RESPONDERS. WE'RE
INTIMATELY FAMILIAR WITH THE
YET UNMITIGATED INCREASINGLY
FREQUENT NUMBER OF VIOLENT ACTS
COMMITTED AGAINST OUR MEMBERS
WHETHER BE UNINTENTIONAL HARM
DONE BY FORENSIC MENTAL HEALTH
PATIENTS OR DELIVER IT INJURY
CAUSED BY CRIMINAL SEALANTS.
OUR MEMBERS ARE SUBJECTED TO
NUMEROUS DANGERS ON A DAILY
BASIS WITH LITTLE TO NO
PHYSICAL PROTECTION. AB SEVEN
IS A NECESSARY STEP TO NOT ONLY
ELIMINATING SUCH IMPOSSIBLE
CHOICES ON THE JOB AT
DETERMINING WHETHER YOU'RE
GOING TO THE LINE OF ACTIVE
FIRE WITHOUT PROPER PROTECTION
FOR TO WAIT AND POTENTIALLY.
LOSE SYMBOL PATIENTS. AND IT
ALSO IS. THE NEED FOR BETTER
EQUIPMENT AND SUCH.
PREPAREDNESS IN UMASS ONCE
AGAIN THE IP REITERATED SUPPORT
FOR EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU SOMEONE ASKED
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WHICH IS TO TAKE A SUPPORT
POSITION ONLY BE SEVEN. THE
SCENE COMING FORWARD TO- CHECK
COMMITTEE ROOM OVER FULL
COMMITTEE ROOM FOR. A WITNESSES
IN THERE ARE NONE WILL GO TO
THE MODERATOR SMARTER TO QUEUE
UP ANY SUPPORT WHEN THIS IS FOR
AB SEVEN AND- ONCE AGAIN PLEASE
LET US KNOW THE NUMBER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE AND THEN.
ZERO AND MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE A
COUPLE COMMENTS COMING THROUGH-
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH LINE NUMBERS.
THANK YOU.
I'LL JUST BE ONE
MORE MOMENT PLEASE. AND AT
FIRST WE GO TO LINE TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
QUERY WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES AND ON
BEHALF OF OUR PRIVATE ECTOR
EMS WORKERS AND LOCAL ONE
ANIMAL ONE CALLING IN SUPPORT
WOULD QUICKLY ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS.
AND LINE. TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR SOMETIMES ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN MEDICAL RESPONSE
UPDATING THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
DUE TO THE RECENT AMENDMENT JMR
HAS MOVED INTO A SUPPORT
POSITION ON EIGHTY SEVEN AND
AGAIN THANKS THE AUTHOR AND
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
ISSUE. THANK YOU. AND MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THAT TIME RETHINK
THANK YOU WHO KNOWS THERE'S NO
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS. TO
THIS BILL WE WILL ASK THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO TAKE IN
OPPOSITION POSITION AB SEVEN IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM. SEEN NONE.
OF WILL LOOK TO THE OVERFLOW
ROOM FOR WITNESSES THERE ARE
NONE. WELCOME BACK TO THE
MODERATOR. AND AS A MODERATOR
TO- PLEASE. QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON THE B.
SEVEN WE APPRECIATE IT. FOUR
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. IN THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO. I AM MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH AT THIS TIME WE WILL
BRING AB SEVEN BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- ARE THERE QUESTIONS
CONCERNS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
OBSCENE NO ONE WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZABLE GIVEN OPPORTUNITY
CLOSE. THANK RICHARD MEMBERS
ARE STRICTLY HAS MY VOTE. ALL
RIGHT- IS THERE A MOTION ON AB
SEVEN. SENATE ROSA WAS MOVE THE
BILL WILL GO TO- PARKINSON FOR
THE ROLL CALL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COURTESY HI WHAT DOES THE I. O.
CHOI BOGUE. NO TROUBLED NOW THE
DESKTOP THE REST SO I LAYERED.
NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE. RATE THE
VOTES CURRENTLY- THREE OZ ONE
NO AND WE'LL KEEP IT ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO WE'LL
MOVE. TO AB THREE SIXTY FOUR
ALSO SOME REMEMBER RODRIGUEZ
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. THIS BILL
WOULD ENSURE THAT ALL OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND TEMPORARY VISA HOLDERS
WHO COME TO CALIFORNIA TO WORK
RECEIVE COMPREHENSIVE
PROTECTIONS FROM WELL
DOCUMENTED DECEITFUL PRACTICES
OF THIRD PARTY FOREIGN LABOR
RECRUITERS. SB THREE SIXTY FOUR
CORRECT A DRAFTING ERROR MADE
IN S. B. FOUR SEVEN SEVEN IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN THAT CREATED
THE FIRST FRAMEWORK FOR
COMPREHENSIVE PROTECTIONS FOR
TEMPORARY VISA HOLDERS. AMONG
ALL TYPES OF VISAS H. TWO A.
VISA PROGRAM IS A TEMPORARY
VISA CATEGORY LINK TO THE
LARGEST NUMBER OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES IN THE UNITED
STATES. NEWLY RELEASED DATA
FROM THE NATIONAL HUMAN
TRAFFICKING HOTLINE DURING THE
PANDEMIC SHOWS THAT AGRICULTURE
WORKERS WITH H. TWO A. VISA
REPORTED 70% MORE CASES OF
TRAFFICKING AND EXPLOITATION.
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND AT
LEAST ONE THIRD OF THE WORKERS
ALSO REPORTED BEING DENIED
MEDICAL ATTENTION AMONG OTHER
ABUSES WHILE THEY WERE DEEMED
ESSENTIAL BY THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT. I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR MAKING
THE POINT DISTINCTION THAT THIS
BILL IS NOT DUPLICATIVE.
ADDITIONALLY I WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT EMPLOYERS
WHO CONTRACT FOR THEIR OWN H.
TWO A. WORKERS WOULD NOT BE
SUBJECT. TO THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THIS BILL WE ARE PLENTY OF
EVIDENCE THAT OUR CURRENT
SYSTEMS BOTH FEDERALLY AND IN
CALIFORNIA DO NOT ADEQUATELY
PROTECT THESE AFFORDABLE
TEMPORARY MIGRANT WORKERS
ENTERING CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE
SERVICES. OF FOREIGN LABOR
RECRUITERS. THIS BILLS INCREASE
PROTECTION WOULD DO JUST THAT I
HAVE COME ALIVE WITH ME TODAY
ON THE LINE TO STEPHANIE
RICHARD REPRESENTING THE
COALITION ABOLISH SLAVERY AND
TRAFFICKING AND- SPEAK TO
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. ALSO
COMING IN AS A VICTIM OF
FOREIGN LABOR GROUP APPROACHES
THIS BILL WOULD ADDRESS. PLEASE
JOIN ME AND PROTECTING THESE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WHO
LEGALLY. ENTER CALIFORNIA TO
FEED THEIR FAMILIES SHOULD BE
SAFE PERSPECTIVE TRAVEL. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WILL
PUT THE STUFF IN THE- RICHARD
AND STEPHANIE IS ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ON- IF YOU'RE
THERE YOU CAN PROCEED. YES MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE RICHARD I'M
CAPTAIN LEVINE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE COALITION TO ABOLISH
SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING CAST
CASHIER BONTA OF AB THREE SIX
FOUR WE'RE ALSO THE LARGEST
LEGAL AND SOCIAL SERVICE
PROVIDER FOR TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS IN THE UNITED STATES.
AFTER SERVICE PROVIDERS
EXPERIENCES WORKING WITH
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS WE LEARNED
THAT ONE OF THE BEST WAY TO
PREVENT TRAFFICKING BEFORE IT
STARTS. IT'S ELIMINATE THE
FRAUDULENT PRACTICE OF THE
THIRD PARTY FOR LABOR
CONTRACTORS AT THE TIME OF
WORKER RECRUITMENT. THE SHADOW
AGENTS FORCED WORKERS INTO DEBT
BY CHARGING THEM EXORBITANT
FEES FOR LEGAL WORK VISAS IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN SB FORTY
SEVEN SEVEN WITH AFTER REMEDY
THIS PROBLEM. AB THREE SIX FOUR
IS NECESSARY FOR THE SAME
REASON SB FOUR SEVEN SEVEN WAS
ELECTED IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN. DOCUMENTED GRAVE AND
WIDESPREAD ABUSE OF THE SYSTEM
INCLUDING HUMAN TRAFFICKING
TRAFFICKING OF THE DIFFICULT
CRIME TO PREVENT BUT TODAY WE
CAN PROTECT THE VULNERABLE
WORKERS. MANY OF WHOM ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS OF THE
HARDEST HIT BY THE BANK AND
DEMOCRATS AND IT'S CONTINUING
NEGATIVE IMPACTS. SB FORTY
SEVEN SEVENS REQUIREMENT AS
CLARIFIED BY AB THREE FIX FOR
OUR SPECIAL FOR PROTECTING ALL
TEMPORARY WORKERS COMING TO
CALIFORNIA. SOMEONE BEAT AROUND
EIGHTY THREE SIX FOUR FOCUSES
ON EACH TO A AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS THAT'S ONLY ABOUT
TWENTY THOUSAND WORKERS. WE
CAN'T LOSE SIGHT OF ALL THE
OTHER VISA CATEGORIES THIS BILL
IS DESIGNED TO COVER ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND WORKERS.
EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT ABUSES
SUFFERED BY WORKERS RECRUITED
BY FOREIGN LABOR CONTRACTORS
ARE THE SAME REGARDLESS OF THE
CATEGORY FOR THAT REASON THE
PROTECTIONS AFFORDED BY EIGHTY
THREE SIX FOUR GOAL WAY BEYOND
THOSE EXISTING CALIFORNIA
FEDERAL LAW. THEY PROVIDE A
SORELY NEEDED CONSISTENT
FRAMEWORK COVERING ALL THESE
TWO CATEGORIES ONE THAT MESHES
WELL BUT DOES NOT OVERLAP WITH
EXISTING PROTECTIONS THE BILL
PROVISIONS ARE ALSO GOOD FOR
BUSINESS. EMPLOYERS WILL NOW
NOT HAVE TO WILL NOW HAVE A
DREADED WITH THE LEGITIMATE
RECRUITERS IF THEY CHOOSE NOT
TO DIRECTLY RECRUIT THEIR OWN
TEMPORARY WORKERS. AND THE
UNFAIR COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE OF
BUSINESSES USING RECRUITERS WHO
UNDERPAY WORKERS WILL BE A
LIMITED THE OPPOSITION'S
ARGUMENT THAT THIS IS DOUBLE
LICENSING OR BURDENSOME IS LIKE
SAYING THAT IF YOU HAVE A
DRIVER'S LICENSE YOU DON'T NEED
TO HAVE A MOTORCYCLE. LICENSE
THE BUSINESS GAUGES AND
DIFFERENT ACTIVITY BASED. HAVE
TO COMPLY WITH THE FOR
OVERSIGHT REGULARLY. ADDITIONAL
IT'S MORE DISTURBING THE AGRIC.
IN THESE ONLY. OPPOSITION TO
THESE NEW A PART. FOR ALL WORK.
AS THE AUTHOR SPOKE ABOUT.
EVERY REPORT SHOWED THE H. TWO
A. CAL. IS THE HIGH. AREA OF
EXPLOITATION AND THAT JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE REPORT BY THE
NATIONAL HUMAN TRAFFICKING-
CENTER GAVE US THAT GRANT.
SUGGESTING THAT SOMEBODY MORE
CASES OF TRAFFICKING
EXPLOITATION 70% OR MORE CASES
OF TRAFFICKING EXPLOITATION
WERE REPORTING DURING THAT A
PANDEMIC. FOR THOSE REASONS I
AM A SURVIVOR CAL. REPRESENTS
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB THREE SIX
FOUR I'LL NOW TURN OVER TO
ANGELA GUNSAN WHO IS A HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SURVIVOR. OF FORCED
LABOR AND YOU CAME. HERE ON A
TEMPORARY WORK VISA. I THINK
YOU STEPHANIE GOOD AFTERNOON
OUT MEANING CENTER GLENN'S I AM
UNABLE TRACKING. ORIGINALLY
FROM THE PHILIPPINES. I DON'T
KNOW IF ANY OF YOU HEARD ME
SPEAK IN SB FOUR SEVEN SEVEN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN- THE
NASAL CANALIS IN FRONT OF THE
LAST NAME BUT I REMEMBER. I
REMEMBER HOW EXCITED I WATCHED
BECAUSE I THOUGHT THIS DEAL
WOULD HAVE REALLY HELPED ME AND
WOULD PROTECT MANY OTHER
IMMIGRANT WORKERS STRIKE ME. I
WAS DEVASTATED WHEN I HEARD
THAT THE BILL WOULD ONLY COVER
EACH TO BE WORKERS. BECAUSE OF
THE DRAFTING ERROR. I DIDN'T
COME TO THE UNITED STATES ON AN
H. TWO B. VISA I CAME ON A P.
ONE VISA. AND HE WAS BECAUSE OF
HOW CONFUSING DIVISA PRACTICE
WISE THAT I ENDED UP TRAFFIC.
COMING TO THE UNITED STATES AND
THE LOVE OF THE CELL WITH THE
PROMISE OF A GOOD JOB. IN THE
PHILIPPINES LIKE WINNING THE
LOTTERY WHEN I GOT MY VISA I
WAS EXCITED. THAT THEY DIDN'T
ASK ME ANY QUESTIONS I CAME TO
THE CALIFORNIA WITH ANY
POLLUTER. BUT MORE THAN TEN
OTHER PEOPLE ON P. ONE VISAS
WHO BELIEVE HE WOULD BE ABLE TO
LEGALLY WORK IN THE UNITED
STATES. WHEN I ARRIVED IN THE
UNITED STATES MY PASSPORT WAS
TAKEN AWAY FROM ME. I WASN'T
GIVEN A CONTRACT- OR TERMS OF
MY EMPLOYMENT BEFORE I LEFT MY
HOME COUNTRY. I WAS TOLD THEY
OWE TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
MY TRANSPORTATION. TO THE
UNITED STATES AND OF THE STAFF.
I WAS TOLD THEY WOULD HAVE TO
WORK ANY. AT A TIME AND HOME
FOR THE L. THE GATE IN LAS. TO
BE OFF THAT. I WORKED EIGHTEEN
HOUR A DAY RECOUNT OFF. AT THIS
REPORT THE FLOOR IN THE HALLWAY.
AND EIGHT DEMOCRATS TRAFFICKER
ALWAYS JACKSON THAT. SHE TOLD
ME IF THE POLICE ON ME. THEY
COULD TAKE US AWAY AND
PRODUCTION JAM. IT'S GOING ON
FOR YEARS I AM NOW WORKING FULL
TIME AS A MEDICAL BILLER AND
SENATE VOICES CONSTANTLY. AT
ONE THE TYPE OF ABUSE THAT
HAPPENED TO ME AND MY COWORKERS
HAPPEN TO OTHER PEOPLE BASED ON
MY OWN EXPERIENCE AND OF OTHER
SURVIVORS IN MY NETWORK. SB
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN SHOULD COVER
MORE TEMPORARY VISA CATEGORIES
THAT EACH TO BE NO TEMPORARY
WORK VISA CATEGORIES SHOULD BE
EXCLUDED FROM THE REGULATIONS
TO PROTECT WORKERS ESPECIALLY
NOW WE DISCARDED NINETEENTH AND
GRAMMY I BELIEVE MANY PEOPLE
NOT ONLY FROM THE PHILIPPINES
BUT ALSO FROM OTHER COUNTRIES
WILL TAKE ANY CHANCES. SAID
THEY NEED EXTRA PROTECTION. NO
ONE SHOULD BE THEY HAVE TO WORK
FOR AN EMPLOYER NINE AND DATE.
AND BE FOR THE POINT I'M FREE
FOR THEIR OWN. AND THE FACT.
AFTER GETTING A READING OF THE
STAR. ALL MIGRANT WORKERS
SHOULD BE. SO WE HAVE
INFORMATION HOME COUNTRY ABOUT
WHAT DIGNITARIES. ARE GOOD AND
FAIR. NOW PREVENTED ME FROM
BEING TRAFFICKED. I HOPE YOU
BOTH I AB THREE SIXTY FOUR
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU AND
THAT CONCLUDES THE LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT FOR ANYONE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WAS TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME
FORWARD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
MATT WAS A WITH THAT SAID YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
PATCHWORK THAT'S BILLS ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTRE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE FOR
CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL ALONG
WITH THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
SIMPLE SAN DIEGO ONE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DA'S OFFICE OR IN
SUPPORT OF THE BUILDING OR CAN
I HELP THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO TAKE A
SUPPORT POSITION IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. LET'S SEE NONE
OTHERS AND THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES PRESENT IN THE
OVERFLOW ROOM PLUS A MODERATOR
TO QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON THIS BILL. FIVE
EIGHT THREE SIXTY FOUR IN THE
PLEASE LET US KNOW THE NUMBER
WITNESSES PRESENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
SIX FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THE END ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND SO
FAR WE HAVE FOUR PEOPLE QUEUED
UP TO PROVIDE COMMENT LET'S
FIRST GO TO LINE TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER PROPOSED IT OFF ON THE
HAVE A LOS ANGELES CITY MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. BLIND TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
TWO. MONICA MURPHY ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. BLIND.
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY ONE. GENERATE
YOU GET AMBIENCE OKAY SO YOU
CALIFORNIA ACTION INSTRUCTOR
PART. THE LION. TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR. YES MY NAME IS
CAROLINE STAPLETON THE PUBLIC
POLICY OFFICER FOR THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO
THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
AND WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES AND WE DO
HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
BRIAN LITTLE- IF YOU'RE ON THE
COASTAL CURRENTS WIND YOU MAY
BEGIN. COLIBRI LITTLE IN HOUSE
YOU MAKE SURE YOU'RE NOT MUTED.
MISTER CHAIR WE DO NOT SHOW
THAT BRIAN LITTLE HAVE
CONNECTED. OKAY ARE WE ALSO
HAVE LISTED MATTHEW ALLEN IS A
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES
MATTHEW ON AVAILABLE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR THIS IS A MAP YOU
CAN HEAR ME YES WE CAN YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
MATTHEW WELL WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION- WE WERE
ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO AB
AT THREE SIXTY FOUR- THE H.
AWAY OF FUTURE PROGRAM WAS NOT
OVERLOOKED DURING THE
DISCUSSION AND- PASSAGE OF THAT
BEFORE SEVEN SEVEN IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN. SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE
THE CHOICES- ALREADY COVERED BY
A VERY RICH FULLY REGULATED AND
RESTRICTIVE APPLICATION PROCESS
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. DANTICAT'S
FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS ARE ALSO
SUBJECT TO CALIFORNIA'S VERY
AESTHETIC AND UNIQUE TIME LABOR
CONTRACTOR REGULATION THAT IS
MANAGED AND OF COURSE THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S. OFFICE THAT-
REGULATIONS RECOVERS FROM THE
CONTRACTORS AND IT ACTUALLY
REPRESENTS A MODEL FOR THE
CREATION OF THAT WERE SET. SO
WHILE WE CANNOT COMMENT ON THE
OTHER I THINK THE CATEGORIES
THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM FROM- SB FORTY SEVEN.
STRAIGHT PROGRAM IS VERY UNIQUE
IN RT ADS- SPECIFIC ABOUT ROBIN
FOR SPENT BOTH THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AND THEN ALSO ABLE TO BE
ENFORCED AND FORMER CONTRACTORS
AT THE STATE LEVEL- AND THE
PROGRAM PLACES HELP TO CURTAIL
HUMAN TRAFFICKING RELATED
ABUSES. I WAS- CALL OUT THAT
UNDER ALSO FEDERAL LAW- THAT-
FROM THE CONTRACTOR NOVEL OF BY
LIKE ANY FEDERAL LAW RELATING
TO- THAT LICENSE OR- THEY CAN
ALSO LOSE THAT LICENSE THAT
FAILED TO ABATE ANY COURT
JUDGMENT BY THE SECTOR OF
LABOR- CONDUCTED AT ANY- NOT.
DONATION THE LAST FIVE YEARS- I
WOULD ALSO REFERENCE THE UNITED
STATES PART OF LABOUR FACT
SHEET ON H. TWO A. WORKERS AND
THE IMMIGRATION NATIONALITY ACT
OUT BOTH EMPLOYERS MUST COMPLY
WITH ALL APPS WILL LAWS AND
REGULATIONS. INCLUDING A
PROHIBITION AGAINST HOLDING OR
CONFISCATING WORKERS PASSPORTS
OR OTHER IMMIGRATION DOCUMENTS.
IN ADDITION EMPLOYERS MUST NOT
SEEK OR RECEIVE PAYMENT OF ANY
KIND FROM WORKERS FOR ANYTHING.
RELATED TO THAT CHIANG H.
RICHARD A- INCLUDING INTO.
ATTORNEY OR A- THE APPLICATION
FEES FOR RECRUITMENT COSTS. SO
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE SUCH
A TO A DUPLICATE ALLIES. SYSTEM
UNDER THE SAME OFFER THE LABOR
OFFICE- WALLY LET REC- IS THE-
OUT THERE THE SPONSOR STILL
THAT SOMETHING IS MISSING WITH
THE FARM UPON. REYES TELLS-
THAT WE HAVE THAT. FIRST JUST
MAKING A OBJECTIVE SEPARATE.
LICENSING PROGRAM IS FOR THOSE
REASONS THAT WE RESPECTFULLY
ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL. OKAY
THANK YOU THAT WOULD CONCLUDE
LEAD OPPOSITE OVER AND COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WISH
TO TAKE IN OPPOSITION. LUCIEN
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM FOR
SO PLEASE STEP FORWARD. LET'S
SEE NONE. I WILL LOOK TO THE
OVERFLOW ROOM FOR WITNESSES IN
THERE ARE NONE. WE WILL PUT TO
THE MODERATOR AND ASK MODERATOR
QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ON AB THREE SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE THANK YOU- THAT
MISTER CHAIR I DO SHOW THAT WE
HAVE BRIAN LITTLE CONNECTED
NOW. BROWN LITTLE ME PROCEED.
MISTER CHAIRMAN- I OPPOSE FOR
MY TARDINESS. THIS IS BRIAN
LITTLE BIT CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
ORGANIZATION OF FARMERS AND
RANCHERS. WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB THREE SIXTY FOUR
BECAUSE OF ONE BECAUSE TO PUT
IT REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS ON
FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE FEDERAL H.
TWO A. TEMPORARY CULTURAL
WORKER VISA PROGRAM. FRAZIER
CULTURAL BOYS ON MANY
CALIFORNIA FARMS. BEFORE WE
WERE CONTRACTORS HAVE FOR
DECADES BEEN REQUIRED TO OBTAIN
AND MAINTAIN THE STATE FARM
LABOR CONTRACTORS LICENSE.
DOING THIS REQUIRES FARM LABOR
CONTRACTORS TO DEMONSTRATE
COMPLIANCE AND SATISFACTION
LABOR COMMISSIONER WITH
NUMEROUS IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS
FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES. INCLUDING
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TRAINING FOR
THEIR PERSONNEL PUSHING AWAY TO
BOND. AND FOR CONTRACTORS
SEEKING INITIAL LICENSE AN
EXTENSIVE EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS. THE CONTINUING
EDUCATION PRESS ALSO USES SEEK
RENEWAL OF THEIR LICENCES. AB
THREE SIXTY FOUR SEEK TO CHANGE
EXISTING CALIFORNIA LAW WHICH
CREATED THE FLC REGISTRATION
REQUIREMENTS. FOR CONTRACTORS
RECRUITING EMPLOYEE PEOPLE WHO
VARIOUS FOREIGN WORKER VISA
PROGRAMS. IN THE LEGISLATURE
PATHOS BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN THE
TWENTY FOURTEEN. BUT BEFORE
SEVENTY SEVEN WAS PASSED THE
OFTEN THE SPONSORS OF US BEFORE
SEVENTY SEVEN MADE A WISE
DECISION TO SPECIFICALLY
EXCLUDE EMPLOYERS WHO MIGHT
OTHERWISE BE COVERED. BY US
BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN
REQUIREMENTS BUT ARE COVERED BY
THE LICENSE REQUIREMENTS
APPLYING TO FARM LABOR
CONTRACTORS. IN THE ASSEMBLY
CONSIDERED AS BEFORE SEVENTY
SEVEN THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE SPECIFICALLY CITED
THE EXISTING CAR LABOR CONTRACT
PROGRAM. AS A REFORM THAT
UNSERVED TO CURTAIL LABOR
TRAFFICKING. THE PROPOSAL SB
THREE SIXTY FIVE YOU THREE
SIXTY FOUR CLAIMS. THAT SEEKS
TO CORRECT THE LOOPHOLES IN THE
LAW CREATED BY AS BEFORE
SEVENTY SEVEN. I WAS SERVING MY
PRESENT POSITION IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND I ENGAGE THE
OFFERS ALSO THAT TIME TO
CONFIRM I UNDERSTAND THIS
BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN WAS NOT
INTENDED TO COVER FARM LABOR
CONTRACTORS. EIGHTY THREE SIXTY
FOUR- SEEKS TO UNNECESSARY
DUPLICATION OF A REGISTRATION
REQUIREMENT FOR FARM LABOR
CONTRACTORS WHO ALREADY
LICENSED BONDED AND SUBJECT TO
EXTENSIVE EDUCATION WILL
CONTINUE TO CASE REQUIREMENTS.
AND MONITORING BUT WE ALSO
HELLO COMMISSIONER. YEAH THE
MAY BY MR ALLEN- THE AFFECTED
WOULD BE WE WOULD- WELL A
CONVERSATION. ABOUT HOW WE
MIGHT ABLE TO ADDRESS. IN THE
PARLOR CONTRACTOR REGISTRATION.
TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS- SET
FORTH BY THE PROPONENTS THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU IN NUMBER.
WE WILL STICK WITH THE
MODERATOR NOW AND ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE. WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB THREE
SIXTY FOUR. IN ADDITION TO THE
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES. ARE
COMMON IN SUPPORT OF AB PREFIX
FOR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO I COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO.
I APOLOGIZE FOR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION. A. B. THREE SIX
FOUR PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO THE
NEXT MAN AGAIN ONE ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR I SHOW NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH AT THE TIME. OKAY THE
MODERATOR OF BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS BY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. FROM SCENE NO ONE
WISHING TO BE RECOGNIZED THE
WILL COME BACK TO THE AUTHOR
FOR YOUR CLOTHES PLEASE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE
STRICTLY OUT FOR A VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. WE ARE LOOKING FOR
MOTION ON AB. THREE SIXTY FOUR.
COOPER STANDARD ROSSELL A WORSE
GOOD FOR ROLL CALL WILL PLEASE
CONSULT. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY
COURTESY HI BUT AS THE I OR
CHOI BOGUE. THE RUSSELL. HI
PLUS I'D LAYERED. THERE ARE AYE
NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE. OKAY THE
FOOD IS SERVED HIM FOR TWO ZERO
WITH ONE ABSTENTION SO THE BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU. REMOVE NOW
STILL WITH THE SEVEN MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ TO AB. SIX ONE FIVE
FOUR SIX FIFTEEN. AND PLUS YOU%
TO GO AHEAD AND PRESENT
DIFFERENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS. AS YOU'RE
AWARE THERE'S A HUGE SHORTAGE
OF LICENSED MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS AND PRACTITIONERS
IN OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM WHICH
WAS HIGHLIGHTED AS A CRITICAL
PONDERING COVERT NINETEEN A. B.
SIX FIFTEEN WAS SIMPLY PROVIDE
MINIMUM EMPLOYMENT RIGHT TO
MEDICAL AND DENTAL BOYS WHO
WORK FOR A HIGHER EDUCATION
EMPLOYER. THESE EMPLOYEES WHO
WORK IN HIGHER EDUCATION GET
THE SKILLS NECESSARY FOR
LICENSURE AND ARE NOT AFFORDED
BASIC RIGHTS REGARDING
DISCIPLINE OR TERMINATION OF
EMPLOYMENT THAT COULD
NEGATIVELY IMPACT FUTURE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES TO DO
SOMETHING MINOR THAT'S
UNRELATED TO A CLINICAL
PRACTICE OR ACADEMICS. BECAUSE
THE ONGOING CRISIS IN
HEALTHCARE TODAY WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT MINOR SUBJECTIVE
DECISIONS DON'T HARM THE FUTURE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES ARE
PROFESSIONALS THAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED TODAY. I WANT
TO NOTE THAT THE SPONSOR AND
THE POINT TO HELP MAKE.
PROGRESS AND I BELIEVE THAT
WILL HAVE AN AGREEMENT TO
REMOVE THE OPPOSITION SHORTLY.
COMING IN TO TESTIFY IN RESPOND
TO TECHNICAL QUESTIONS OR MOUNT
THE J. WITH SLU AND DR PAUL
WALLACE. ARGYRAKIS RIVALS.
THANK YOU FOR THE ITEM WILL
GOOD LEADS FOR WHEN THIS IS AN
ANALOGY PLEASE SIR YOU MAY
PROCEED. AT THANK YOU I'M A
PERSON. WHO ARE IN PERSON I SEE
YOU THERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THAT CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- MET WITH HIM
BEHALF AS A YOU CALIFORNIA- THE
SPONSORS OF AB SIX ONE FIVE-
THIS BILL WOULD GRANT BASIC DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS TO INTERNS AND
RESIDENTS AND THEY'RE CURRENTLY
THE ONLY- YOU SEE EMPLOYEE WHO
DOES NOT HAVE THOSE RIGHTS. AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID IT WOULD
ENSURE THAT- SOMETHING SIMPLE
WOULD NOT DERAIL SOMEONE'S
CAREER AS THEY PUT YOU KNOW
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS AND
SIGNIFICANT STUDENT DEBT OFTEN-
TO PURSUE THEIR DREAM BECOMING
A PHYSICIAN- S. YEAH YOU HAS-
SIMILAR DUE PROCESS RIGHTS IN
FIFTY SEVEN OTHER- CONTRACTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND THE
UNITED STATES- AND SO THIS IS A
REALLY STANDARD PRACTICE IN
MANY OF THESE ECONOMIC FEELS.
AND SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
WORKED ON WITH THE UC'S AND
GOOD FAITH AND- I WOULD ECHO
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S COMMENTS
AND A COMMAND DAY YOU SEE AND-
OUR WORK TOGETHER TO REALLY
COME UP WITH A DEFINITION OF
ACADEMIC AND CLINICAL THAT
WORKS FOR BOTH SIDES AND
BELIEVE THAT WE WILL HAVE AN
AGREEMENT SHORTLY. SO AT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND- RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
OKAY THANK YOU AND IS A DOCTOR
PAUL. WALLACE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ONE. I AM NOT
PLEASE PROCEED. MY NAME IS PAUL
KERN GOOD YEAR PSYCHIATRY
RESIDENT YOU SEE A THAT THANK
YOU FOR ME TODAY AND OF A. SIX
ONE FIVE. CORRECT IT BACK TO
NORMAL ABOUT THE TIME MONEY TO
OUR TRAIN. IT IS SOMEONE IT
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR A STUDENT LOAN DAD INTO
GOT OUT THE TWENTY FOUR HOUR
SHIFTS. IT WAS A VERY POOR BILL
TO DO WE DO PARTNER TO MASTER.
INSTRUCTOR UNITY NOW AND
DECADES TO COME OUT WE GRADUATE.
THEY. C. GIVEN LARGER GOING
TOWARD OF POSITION AND CAL.
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE TO START PIPELINE DO
BECAUSE THAT'S VETERAN
WORKFORCE. YOU CAN DO SPECIFIC
ABOUT DUE PROCESS TODAY BECAUSE
KERN AND CAL. RIGHT IF YOU
FIRED THE RESCUE PROGRAM START
ACTING ANY TYPE OF APPEAL
PROCESS. COMPARED THE WHIM OF
THE RESIDENCY PROGRAM DIRECTOR.
BEING FIRED FROM RESIDENCY IS
DEVASTATING. DEFENSIVE MEANS
WE'LL NEVER BILL TO PRACTICE
MEDICINE AGAIN. HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS AND YEARS
OF HARD WORK WASTED. DREAMS OF
LONG CAREERS DEVOTED TO HELPING
OTHER SHATTERED. NO SINGLE
PERSON HAS THE POWER TO FIRE
RESIDENT HISTORICALLY AIR
DEPRIVE CALIFORNIA MUCH YOU TO
POSITION. WITHOUT DOUBT RENT
AND HAVING ACCESS TO A NEUTRAL
THIRD PARTY ARBITRATOR. GET THE
TERMINATION UNDER LEGALLY
BINDING. FISHING SPECTER BE
RARE A WORK ISSUE GOT ARBOR.
BUT INCREDIBLY AND THAT ARE
EXIST THESE ARE. IT'S CURRENT
EARLY UNDER INDEPENDENT EAD
FOR SPEAKING OUT ABOUT ON PAPER
QUITE CONDITIONS. MICHAEL TO
PERSONAL. EQUIPMENT AT TIMES IT
CREATES ENORMOUS FROM HOSPITAL
WHERE SITE TO MAKE ME LOOK BAD.
NO NOW THAT'S BEING UP LIKELY
THE LIVES OF PATIENTS NOT ON.
MONTEREY BY TO BOSTON PER UNDER
THE GUISE OF PROVIDE. CHANGE
WAY THEY DO. SPEAK AND MORE
THAN. BUT THEIR ORDER MORE
CONCERT PROGRAM DIRECTORS.
PRESIDENCY ACTED PROP TO
PROTECT US FROM ON PUNISH WHICH
UP FOR OURSELVES. OUR
COLLEAGUES ARE PATIENT. SB SIX
ONE FIVE ONE THAT READ HAVE
BACK TO DO. AND WILL INSURE CAL
HAS THE- POSITION OR POSSIBLE.
CHECK WE ASK WHERE I MONEY GET
SIX ONE FIVE. OKAY THANK YOU WE
ARE GOING TO ASK DOES ANYBODY
IN THE ROOM WHO SUS IS. A
SUPPORT POSITION ON THIS BILL
AND WE SEE FOLKS COMING FORTH
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND OTHER SHEA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT. A SOPHOMORE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. JOHN
RUNNING ON BEHALF OF THE UC AFT
THE UNIVERSE IT'S LIBRARIANS
LECTURES AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. MICHAEL
YOUNG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS ALSO IN
SUPPORT. OKAY THANK YOU BERMAN
WE WILL NOW GO TO THE OVERFLOW
ROOM AND SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
THERE WHO. NEEDS TO SPEAK IN
THERE IS NOT WILL GO TO THE
MODERATOR ASKED. OF THE MOTOR
TO QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON AB. SIX ONE FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
ONE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THE END ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND MISTER
CHAIR SO FAR WE HAVE THREE P.
I'M SORRY FOR PEOPLE QUEUED UP
TO GET A COMMENT LINE TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY YEAR MY COULD
OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BEEN ASKING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIX ONE FIVE. THE LINE A ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY. THANK YOU THIS
IS MERE MCIVER WITH UNIVERSITY
COUNCIL AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS ALSO KNOWN AS YOU SEE
A- REPORT. BLIND. TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
TERROR MEMBERS RON RAPP ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. BLIND. TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE. LINE TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
SORRY COMMITTEE ON TRANSOXIANA
POLLSTERS. AND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THE TIME. OKAY ARMS WILL NOTE
THAT THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION- WITNESS IDENTIFIED
ONLY BE SIX FIFTEEN IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WHICH IS TO TAKE IN OPPOSITION
POSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEING NONE I WILL CHECK WITH
YOUR FOR ROOM THERE'S NO
WITNESSES THERE AND WE WILL
COME BACK TO THE MODERATORS AND
ASK YOU. TO CALL ON ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON THE B.
SIX FIFTEEN PLEASE THANK YOU.
OR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO A.
B. SIX FIFTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. BACK COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. IN THAT LANE
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY NINE YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M SURE MEMBERS
MICHAEL BERNARD ON HALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THE
PRESIDENT. HAS NOT BECAUSE I'M
NOT FROM AN INTERNATIONAL SB
SIX G. THANK. AND MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR AND WILL BRING THIS
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS SHEARITH
COMMITTEE. ON THE SCENE NO ONE
WISHING TO BE RECOGNIZED- WOULD
GIVE ME AN OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE
NOW SOME MEMBERS. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE STRUCK OUT
FIVE VOTE. THANK YOU THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR LAYERED
IN WAS CANCELLED THE CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COURTESY BY PROTESTS CHAU CHOI
BOGUE NO A TROUBLED NOW LET US
ALL. RUSSELL I LAYERED HI THERE
I NEWMAN. NEWMAN HI THE FOOD IS
FOUR TO ONE THE BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU. NO THE FOURTH AND
FINAL ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
BILL FOR TODAY A. B. ELEVEN OH
FIVE. AND AGAIN YOU MAY PRESENT
AS SOON AS YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
FIRST THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN FOR
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT. AB ELEVEN
OH FIVE BEFORE I BEGIN I WOULD
LIKE TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THIS MEASURE IS
ABOUT PROTECTING OUR HEALTH
CARE WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
AS THEY CONTINUE TO BE ON THE
FRONT LINES. BATTLING THIS
PANDEMIC THAT HAS PERSISTED FOR
WELL OVER A YEAR AS WE HAVE
SEEN SINCE THE START OF THIS
PANDEMIC THE FAILURE TO SCREEN
TEST AND TRACE ALL CORPORATE
NINETEEN AFFECTIONS HAS
RESULTED IN UNDETECTED
TRANSMISSION DELAYED CRITICAL
TREATMENT AND SPEEDING UP THE
VIRUS'S SPREAD SPREAD OF THE
VIRUS. IN NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUE GUIDANCE FOR
WEEKLY TESTING OF HEALTH CARE
WORKERS A. B. ELEVEN OH FIVE
WOULD BUILD ON THAT GUIDANCE BY
REQUIRING EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE.
PP TO HOSPITAL PLOYS DEVELOP A
PROGRAM TO OFFER WEEKLY TESTING
FOR PERSONAL AND REQUIRE
EMPLOYERS TO TEST PATIENTS FOR
COOPER NINETEEN PRIOR TO
ADMISSION. WITH THE NEW
DIFFERENT BRANDS OF THE VIRUS
EMERGING WITH THE REPORTS THAT
ANOTHER DOSAGE OF THE VACCINE
MAY BE NECESSARY THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY TO SAFEGUARD OUR
HOSPITAL FROM MY WORKERS FROM
CORPORATE NINETEEN. AS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD I WILL
CONTINUE TO GAUGE WITH
SIGNATUREON THE CONCERNS THAT
THEY HAVE RAISED TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY TO HELP ANSWER
QUESTIONS TODAY IT'S CURTIS
FIND WITH THE CALIFORNIA.
NURSES ASSOCIATION WHO SHOULD
BE ON THE LINE. BURUTU IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE YOU MAY
PURSUE. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS INTEREST LYING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
REGISTERED NURSES PROBABLY WILL
MAYBE ELEVEN O'CLOCK. WE THANK
AND APPRECIATE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RODRIGUEZ SCORES LEADERSHIP AND
BRING FORTH THIS MUCH NEEDED
PROTECTIVE MEASURE MORE THAN
FIFTEEN INTO THE CLOVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THE CALLING
OF OURS IS STILL SPREADING INTO
THE BOX THE NIGHT STATE AND
AROND THE WORLD. AT THE TO
DATE LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA EVERY QUARTER
HUNDRED THIRTEEN THOUSAND AND
NINETY EIGHT CONFIRMED PUBLIC
CULVERTED NINETEEN CASES IN
NURSES AND HEALTHCARE WORKERS
AND FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
DEATHS. THIS FIGURE INCLUDES.
ON THE JOB EXPOSURES. RIGHT NOW
TRACK MISTER WHAT THE HELL
FACILITIES WE MORE MAIL.
INCLUDING KATE THE DETECTION
AND ISOLATION VENTILATION
RESPIRATORY PROTECTION BACKING
THE MORE. EVEN MEDICAL GRADE
NINETEEN VACCINATION RATE
INCREASE CASTING IN BRINGING
PROGRAMS TO PATIENTS AND
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AS REQUIRED
IN AB ELEVEN OH FIVE REMAIN
IMPORTANT TO TACK AND ISOLATE.
CAPERS IN HEALTH CARE FOR SO.
BACK IN THE ORDER IN ALLEN TO
REDUCING THE SPREAD OF OVER
NINETY. BUT WE CANNOT RELY ON
BACKING THE LOAN TO STOP
TRANSMISSION APPROPRIATE. IT IS
CLEAR THE HOBBIT NINETEEN
BACKING DARK FACT ABOUT
PREVENTING SEVERE OKAY NINETEEN
HOSPITAL HOSPITALIZATION AND
DEATH BUT NO BACK TO THE 100%
EFFECTIVE AND THERE ARE MANY
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS ABOUT OVER
NINETEEN BACK THE- INCLUDING
HOW LONG PROTECTION WILL ALLOW.
THE NEED FOR BOOSTERS. WHAT
PROTECTION AGAINST MYLAN AND
EIGHT OF THE MEDICAID LOOK LIKE
AND HOW EFFECTIVE VACCINE WILL
BE AGAINST PARENTS OF CONCERN.
THAT ARE THAT ARE OR MAY.
BECOME RESISTANT TO VACCINES.
CNN HAD LAW AFTER FOR AN
APPROACH TO CONTROL CARBON THAT
ALL THE PROCESS FROM. WHICH
SAID IT'S BEST TAKE THIS RIGHT.
WE DON'T KNOW FOR SURE WHETHER
SOMETHING IS. FOR TAXIS AND
HEALTHCARE SPENDING IN RECALL
BUT NINETEEN TECHNIQUES GREEN
REMAIN VITAL TO PROTECT PATIENT
AND HEALTHCARE WORKERS HEALTH
AND SAFETY. I'M NOT TREATING
PATIENTS AND HEALTHCARE WORKERS
HOSPITALS FAIL TO ENSURE PROPER
PRECAUTIONS ARE IN PLACE TO
PREVENT TRANSMISSION WITHIN THE
FACILITY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ MENTIONED. SEAN
CONTENT THAT THESE HIGH
COMMENDED OR NO LONGER WARM
HERE AND THAT CALIFORNIA'S
WOMAN UPWARD SWING. WE HAVE
MADE SOME PROGRESS IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THE PROBLEM THE
VARIANT. EVEN THE PERVASIVENESS
OF VACCINE RESISTANT FIVE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS COMMUNITY
AND THE LACK OF AN APPROVED
VACCINE CHILDREN UNDER TWELVE
OR SERIOUSNESS SHE- CHILDREN
UNDER THE AGE OF TWELVE.
BRIDEWELL 15% OF THE COUNTRY'S
POPULATION AND THEY CURRENTLY
HAVE NO ACCESS TO GO BUT
NINETEEN VACCINES SO THESE
ISSUES IN THE CASE THAT WE ARE
NOT ALL THE WORDS AND THAT
THERE'S STILL WORK TO DO TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S. URGENT
AND CRITICAL IN NINETEEN
PARENTS OF CONCERNED ARE MORE
TRANSMISSIBLE. DEADLIER AND R.
OR ME BECOME RESISTANT TO
VACCINES TO GIVE UP ALL PARKING
CONSIDERING RELAXING PROTECTIVE
MEASURES. EVEN ABSOLUTELY THE
TO THE PROFESSIONAL IN COLLEGE
BASKETBALL FOOTBALL AND
BASEBALL PLAYERS ARE ROUTINELY
TESTED SOMETIME DALY BUT
HEALTHCARE WORKERS CAN SAVE
LIVES STILL CANNOT FIND OUT
EASILY IF THEY HAVE WILL BE
NINETEEN. IN ORDER TO PROTECT
HEALTHCARE WORKERS PATIENTS AND
OVERALL COMMUNITY THE
PROTECTIVE MEASURES OUTLINED
THIS BILL MUST BE IMPLEMENTED.
YOUR SEATS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR ARTICLE ON AB ONE FIVE
TODAY AND I AM AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- COOL MOVES TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. OF FOLKS WANT
TO. INDICATE A SUPPORT POSITION
ON AB ELEVEN OH FIVE. WELCOME
MANILA SHARE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
SUPPORT. RUINOUSLY COMMITTEE
ROOM WISHING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
POSITION SEEN NONE WILL CHECK
YOUR FOR ROOM FOR WITNESSES
SEEN NONE WILL GO TO THE
MODERATORS. AND ASK FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN OH FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
MINUTE THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. WHEN I SHOW NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THIS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU I WILL
COME BACK IN NOTE THAT THERE'S
NO LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
THERE ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM IT LOOKS LIKE THERE IS-
WISHING TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
POSITION. YOU MISTER PORTER
THIS TIME. CORRECT GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RUNNING WE DO HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION. WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE IN THE AUTHOR TAKING
SOME AMENDMENTS. TO THE BILL
REGRETTABLY WE REMAIN OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED TO THE BILL
UNLESS SOME OF OUR MODEST MORE
MODEST CHANGES ARE MADE- BEFORE
DURING. AND POST PANDEMIC
CALIFORNIA'S HOSPITALS. I HAVE
COMMUNITY THAT'S ALL YOU'RE
ALLOWED TO CITY IN
PENNSYLVANIA. IT'S TAKING A
SUPPORT POSITION WE- WE DO NOT
HAVE YOU DONE AS A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS SO WHAT
YOU'RE STEPPING UP FOR YEAH I.
I BELIEVE WE'RE THE ONLY
ORGANIZATION OPPOSITION BUT YOU
HAVE TO ALERT THE COMMITTEE
AHEAD OF TIME IF YOU WISH TO BE
IN OPPOSITION WITH MISSILE FOR
CAN BE PREPARED FOR THAT. OKAY
BERMAN I'M GONNA MAKE AN
EXCEPTION BECAUSE I MADE ONE
EARLIER- FOR SOMEBODY BUT
GENERALLY SPEAKING ON MAKE IT
CLEAR THE COMMITTEE WERE NOT TO
DO THAT. PEOPLE NEED TO LET THE
COMMITTEE STUFF NORTH ARE GOING
TO BE. SPEAKING AS LEADER
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. THANK YOU
GO AHEAD AND PROCEED I THINK
THE NEXT- BEFORE DOING A POST
BY DEMOCRATS FOR HIS HOUSE.
HAVE A CONTINUE PROTECTING CARE
FOR- NOT JUST OUR PATIENTS BUT
ALSO OUR EMPLOYEES- CONSISTENT
WITH EXISTING LAW. AS WELL AS
EVOLVING- EVOLVING SCIENCE
BASED ON GUIDANCE FROM BOTH THE
CDC MC PH- FOR INFECTION
CONTROL AND PREVENTION- AS
AMENDED AB ELEVEN OH FIVE WOULD
CREATE MANDATES. NINE
DEFINITIONS ON A LINE WITH THE
LATEST- EVIDENCE BASED- GOT
GUIDANCE FROM CDC OR C. PH-
CREATING A CONFLICTING SET OF
RULES FOR HOW TO BEST PROTECT
PATIENTS WORKERS. FINALLY THE
BILL WOULD CREATE ENOUGH
PRESIDENTE LIABILITY FOR PAGA.
WHICH MOST OF US AND- MOST OF
US KNOWS POGBA- WHICH IS
PRIVATE ATTORNEYS GENERAL ACT
WHICH EXISTS FOR EMPLOYEES- AND
APPLY THIS LIABILITY TO PORTS
TESTING- TOWARDS THE TESTING OF
PATIENTS WHICH IS CLEARLY
INAPPROPRIATE- IS. NOT A LABOR
LAW ISSUE- BECAUSE OF THOSE
CONCERNS ARMAMENTS WOULD SIMPLY
REQUEST THE FOLLOWING NUMBER
ONE- TO ALIGN THE PROVISION OF
PP TO EMPLOYEES BASED ON THE
LATEST GUIDANCE FROM CDC OR C.
PH. TO ALIGN THE DEFINITION OF
EXPOSURE TO COOPERATE WITH THE
EXISTING LAW- TO ACCOUNT FOR
THE COVER BACKS NATION STATUS
OF THE PATIENT AND TO ALIGN THE
TESTING- AND MONITORING OF SAID
PATIENTS WITH THE LATEST CD C.
OR C. TO PEACH GUIDANCE. ON AND
FINALLY WE WANT TO LINE THE
SUNSET OF THE BILL. BILL'S
PROVISIONS- WITH EXISTING WITH
OTHER. A COUPLE RELATED
LEGISLATION THAT HAS PASSED
RECENTLY BY THE LEGISLATURE-
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S MINOR SENATE
THOSE AMENDMENTS. WILL BE TAKEN
TODAY COMMITTEE- BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR- IN THE THAT WE FIND
THAT MIDDLE. SO THAT FOR THOSE
RE WE RISK. REQUEST YOUR VOTE
TODAY- BUT TO TAKE ANY FOR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANKS
FOR THE EXCEPTION. OKAY THANK
YOU- ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO TAKE OF AN OPPOSE
POSITION ON THE BILL. AB ELEVEN
OH FIVE. AM SEE NONE SEEN NO
ONE IN THE OVERFLOW ROOM. PER
SE- WE WILL MOVE TO THE
MODERATOR NESS MODERATOR- TO
QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION ON A.
B. ELEVEN OH FIVE. FOR COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION TO A BI ELEVEN OH
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE
END ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO. AND I SHOW NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THE
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AT THIS TIME IN CENTER ALERTED
US TO BE RECOGNIZED I JUST HAD
A QUICK QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR
BUT THE OPPONENT INDICATED THAT
THERE WERE. SOME MORE MODEST
THINGS THEY WERE STILL
INTERESTED IN ARE YOU
CONTINUING TO TALK TO THEM AS
IF THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD YES
I KNOW THERE ARE BROUGHT UP
SOME GOOD POINTS WE KNOCKED TO
TALK WITH THEM TO SEE WE CAN DO
BUT- WANTED TO. CONTINUE
EXPORTS SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS THEY HAVE OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
DANCE. THIRD ROW- YES SIGN UP-
I JUST AS A FOLLOW P TO MY
COLLEAGUE'S QUESTION IS I THINK
THINGS LIKE- ALIGNING WITH THE
CDC OR MAYBE EVEN I'M NOT SURE
HOW MUCH- IF IT APPLIES THE
CALLOW SHAA- THIS SEEMS TO BE A
LITTLE BIT OF A- NOT IN YOUR
BILL BUT JUST OVERALL. A LOT
CHANGING RIGHT NOW AND I'M NOT
SURE WHAT POSITION WHERE AND
I'LL I'LL SUPPORT YOUR BILL
BUT- I WOULD URGE YOU ALSO TO-
LOOK INTO THESE OTHER ISSUES.
REFERRAL CENTER LOOKING TO ME
ONE. OKAY ANYBODY ALSO CENTER
NEWMAN AND THANK YOU MISTER
SERVE ASSEMBLYMAN RODRIGUEZ
SAID RIGHT BY MY OUR STAMINA-
THIS IS LIKE ONE OF THOSE
EPISODES ARE JEOPARDY WE JUST
KEEP WINNING AND WINNING AND
WINNING- BUT JUST TO ADD ON TO
MY COLLEAGUES COMMITTEE YOU AND
I BOTH- PARTICIPATED IN THE
REGULAR MEETINGS- WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S STAFF ON. A PANDEMIC
RELATED ISSUES FOR THE PAST SIX
MONTHS. AND YOU KNOW CLEARLY WE
HAVEN'T WE'RE NOT THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC BUT WE HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS BUT- IT'S
AN EVOLVING SITUATION AMONG
OTHER THINGS WE KNOW THAT THE
GUY OF THE MATURE AND THE PRICE
OF EXCHANGER ARE ARE VERY
EFFECTIVE- APPARENTLY THEY THEY
ARE. OFFERING NEARLY FOR AN
EXTENDED PERIOD TIME. AND ONE
OF THE MOST STRIKING FEATURES.
OF THE CURRENT SITUATION AS WE
LOOK AT. THE REQUIREMENTS HERE
FOR COVER TESTING IS THAT
HEALTH CARE WORKERS THEMSELVES.
HAVE FAILED TO GET IMMUNIZED TO
ADD NUMBERS THAT WE EXPECTED I
KNOW THAT'S NOT. ADDRESSED IN
YOUR BILL- BUT I SHARE THE
CONCERNS. OF THE HOSPITAL
SITUATION THAT WE MAY NOT BE
SOLVING THE RIGHT PROBLEM IN
THIS CASE- SO I WOULD URGE YOU
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION- PARTICULAR AROUND
ALIGNING THE CDC GUIDANCE AS MY WHO HAVE POINT OUT
BUT ALSO- TO RECONCILING THE
SUNSET. BY AND WE CAN DO THAT-
BY WILL. VOTE FOR THE BILL
TODAY BUT I'LL RESERVE THE
RIGHT TO LOOK AT IT HAS COME TO
THE FLOOR THANK YOU. THANK
RIMEGEPANT DEFINITELY LOOKING
AS WELL. THANK THANK YOU THANK
YOU- ASSEMBLY AND APPRECIATE
YOU WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
ON THE AMENDMENT SO YOU'VE
TAKEN- THAT I'M GRATEFUL FOR I
KNOW THAT THERE'S SOME. HEY I
WITH ECHO I WOULD ASK- MOST OF
MY COLLEAGUES CONCERNS A ABOUT
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION REGARDING- SENSIBLE
AMENDMENTS OF THAT. CAN BE DONE
I'M NOT IT'S CLEAR ON THE
SUNSET IS- I THINK SOME PEOPLE
ARE I THINK AS EVERY DAY GOES
BY WE'RE HEARING MORE AND MORE
ABOUT LONG HAUL. SYMPTOMS SONG
WHICH WERE A SIGNIFICANT AND-
HE IN- I JUST WANT TO BE ON THE
RECORD AS SAYING THAT I
APPRECIATE YOUR SENSITIVITY
THAT ISSUE- REGARDLESS OF WHERE
YOU ULTIMATELY LAND I THINK
IT'S AN AREA WHERE THE SCIENCE
TEST ABSOLUTELY BI FOLD SO.
THOSE ARE JUST SOME EDITORIAL
COMMENTS ON MY PART- AGAIN
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE AND
YOU. ARE WELCOME TO CLOSE AT
THIS TIME. THANK WITHOUT A
MISTER GERMAN VERSION OF
STRICTLY AS PRIVATE THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT- DO WE HAVE. A MOTION
THEN TO MOVE THE BILL. AS
AMENDED. COOPER SAID ROSE WAS A
MAY- CONSULTANT TO YEARS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COURTESY HI BUT
DOES THE AYE CULTURE BOOK NO
BUT TROUBLED NOW MODESTO. THE I
LAYERED ON LATER AYE NEWMAN.
NEWMAN I FOR A DIRT DOES PASS
FOR OUR IS TO ONE NO SO THE
BILL ITSELF BEGINNER THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. REFUTED IT WILL
MOVE TO THE LAST BILL ON OUR
AGENDA TODAY IF I'M COUNTING
CORRECTLY- OTHER THAN. LIFTING
THE CALL WHICH WE STILL HAVE TO
DO- A. B. TEN THIRTY ONE. THE
OF PUT WHAT FOOD PRODUCTION
INCORRECTLY SIR. NINE THANK YOU
AND- WE KNOW WE'RE STANDING
BETWEEN YOU AND A FOUR SESSION
EVIDENTLY BUT YOU'RE STANDING
BETWEEN US AND DINNER SO. RIGHT
WELL AS A NEW PRESSURE RIGHT
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS- FIRST
I WANT TO START BY THANKING YOU
AND YOUR STAFF WORKING WITH OUR
OFFICE TO CLARIFY THE LANGUAGE.
AND ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATIONS AN INDEPENDENT
AND AMENDMENTS. AB TEN THIRTY
ONE WAS SIMPLY SIMPLY REQUIRE
THE STATE AGENCIES TO GIVE
ADDITIONAL PREFERENCE TO
SURVIVORS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WHEN HIRING FOR INTERNSHIPS AND
STUDENT ASSISTANT PROGRAMS. A
KEY FEATURE OF HELPING
SURVIVORS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
IS OBTAINING ECONOMIC.
EMPOWERMENT AB TEN THIRTY ONE
WILL TEACH BOTH DO JUST THAT
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TEN THIRTY ONE IS
DO WELL GOMEZ CEO OF THE
CHILDREN'S HOME OF STOCKTON AND
THE CHEER A SAMPSON COUNTY
HUMAN TRAFFICKING TASK FORCE
AND SUSAN THE SUZANNE'S JOLTS
WITH THE SAMPSON COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SUSAN
SCHULTZ SOON IF YOU ARE
PREPARED ON THE TELECONFERENCE
ON YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR CORTESE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT THANK YOU FOR THE
WORK YOU'RE DOING FOR AS OUR
REPRESENTATIVES. I THANK YOU
ALSO FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TEN THIRTY ONE. AGAIN MY
NAME IS SUZANNE SCHULTZ I AM A
PUBLIC SERVANT WHO HAS
PASSIONATELY SERVED MY
COMMUNITY FOR THIRTY SIX YEARS.
I AM A STAFF MEMBER OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY DIFFERENT
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
WHERE I SERVED AS THE PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER.
AS YOU MAY KNOW THE CALIFORNIA
HAS THE LARGEST NUMBER OF
FAMILY JUSTICE CENTERS IN THE
NATION AT TWENTY FIVE. WE ALL
ARE SERVING HUMAN TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS. MULTI DISCIPLINARY
GOVERNMENTAL AND NONPROFIT
PARTNERS COME TOGETHER UNDER
ONE ROOF TO BETTER SERVE
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CHILD ABUSE SEXUAL ASSAULT
STALKING ELDER ABUSE AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. HOPE IS A DRIVING
FACTOR FOR SURVIVORS HOPE FOR A
SAFE PLACE TO LIVE HOPE FOR THE
GRANTING OF PROTECTIVE ORDERS
HOPE TO BE ABLE TO GET THROUGH
THE TRAUMA. FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS HOPE FOR
FUTURE EMPLOYMENT OUTSIDE OF
THE LIFE IS AT THE FOREFRONT
FOR MANY. A VAST MAJORITY OF
THE TRAFFICKING VICTIMS THAT I
HAVE WORKED WITH ENTERED INTO
THE WORLD OF EXPLOITATION AS
CHILDREN BETWEEN THE AGES OF
TWELVE AND FIFTEEN YEARS. THEY
ARE DISCARDED LIKE TRASH WHEN
THEY'RE LUCRATIVENESS AND
APPEAL DIMINISH BY THEIR MID TO
LATE TWENTIES. MANY DO NOT
POSSESS HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS AS
THEY WERE PREYED UPON WHEN IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL. SURVIVORS
POSSESS LIFE EXPERIENCES IN THE
UNDERBELLY OF THE EXPLOITATION
INDUSTRY THAT MANY OF US CANNOT
GRASP. A SURVIVOR ONCE SAID TO
ME I APPRECIATE YOUR BACKPACK
OF FOOD AND TOILETRIES BUT WHAT
I REALLY NEED IS A JOB.
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES WILL
PROVIDE HOPE FOR SURVIVORS AND
THE REALIZATION THAT THEY ARE
VALUABLE. THEY WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REGAIN THE POWER
OF THE TRAJECTORY OF THEIR
LIVES. MANY OF THE SURVIVORS
I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
ASSISTING HAVE EXPRESSED THEY
WANT TO PURSUE OPPORTUNITIES TO
HELP OTHERS. THIS LEGISLATION
IS THE FIRST STEP IN OPENING
THE DOOR OF OPPORTUNITY FOR
THEM WHICH WILL BENEFIT ALL OF
US. DESERVE A HOPE FILLED HEART
THAT I SUPPORT THE PASSAGE OF
AB TEN THIRTY ONE AND I THINK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THIS COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU IN THE WILL NOW. GO TO DO
WELL GOMEZ. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATOR THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
THIRTY ONE. I WANT TO ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE ANYTHING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BILL COULD LOT FOR
CAMPING- ISSUE MY NAME IS
YOU'RE WELCOME AS I'M CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE
CHILDREN STOCKTON AND I CHAIR
THE SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY HUMAN
TRAFFICKING TASK FORCE I THE
TWENTY EIGHT YEAR ADVOCATING.
FOR SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. WELL FAULT AND KNOW
TRACK. IN MY CAPACITY AT
CHILDREN- WOULD PROVIDE THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF CARE FOR UP TO
TWO HUNDRED AFTER YOU EACH YEAR
STOCKTON CORRECT SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY AND- CALIFORNIA. OUR
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES I THANK
JUMPER AFTER THAT WITH YOU HAVE
A PLACE TO LIVE WHILE RECEIVING
CRITICAL RESIDENTIAL PORTABLE.
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES BUT IF YOU CONVENTION
EDUCATION TRANSITION AFTER CARE
FOR THE BOTH. A CROCK MEDLEY
AND CONSERVATIVELY 30% OF THE
YEAR BECAUSE WE THIRD PARTY
PROVIDERS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
OR AT RISK OF BEING RECRUITED
AND LURED INTO THE DARK WORLD.
OUR HOPE PROGRAM BUT DIFFICULT
FOCUSES ON THE UNIQUE NEEDS AND
CHALLENGES THAT BECOMES TRAFFIC
EIGHT. WHEN IT COMES TO
UNDERSTANDING THE COMPLEXITIES
THAT KEEP YOU IN THE DARK WHILE
THE PROPERTY COVERAGE FROM THE
TRAUMA REBUILDING THEIR LIVES
AND IN SOME CASES TRANSITIONING
TO AN INDEPENDENT LIVING
ARRANGEMENT. I KEY FEATURE
ACCORDING PROVIDERS IN THE LONG
TERM EFFECT FACT IT ACCESS TO A
REASONABLE AND ATTAINABLE AND
ON. OPPORTUNITY. FOR ECONOMIC
EMPOWERMENT. BUT OF A TEN
THIRTY. WHAT GROW UP WAY AND
THAT THE DRIVER DID NOT FALL
BACK INTO TRACK. BECAUSE THE
LACK THEM ONE OR IN POCKET.
BERMAN TRAFFIC PERSON ECONOMIC
TOP. FOR IT CHAU. WITH THEM.
HOW GENERATE LIKE INTERNSHIP
ARE THERE. OKAY BERMAN NEATLY A
TOPIC HE THAT YOU. ON A LONG
TERM MAILING COSTS THAT. AT TO
A POINT OPPORTUNITIES THAT CAN
PROVIDE ECONOMIC SECURITY AND
STABILITY CRITICAL SAFETY AND
LONG TERM RECOVERY PROVIDED THE
KEY TRAFFICKING. THEREFORE I
URGE THE PASSAGE OF EIGHTY
POINT. THIRTY ONE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. OKAY THANK
YOU AND WILL COME BACK THE
COMMITTEE ASK THURSDAY JUNE THE
COMMUNITY WHO WAS TO TAKE A
SUPPORTERS ON THE BILL SO PER
STOP. ASEAN AND NO ONE IN OVER
ROOM WE'LL GO TO THE MODERATOR
NESS MODERATOR. A TO PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES
ON AB TEN THIRTY ONE AM PLEASE
LET US KNOW THE NUMBER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR COMMENTS
IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN THIRTY
ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE
ZERO. CAN I SHOW NO COMMENTS
COMING THROUGH AT THE TIME OKAY
THANK YOU WE HAVE A NEW LEADER
OPPOSITION WITNESS- IDENTIFIED
IN A NON STEPPING FORWARD- WE
WILL ASK- IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO
WISHES TAKE AN OPPOSITION
POSITION IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
SO PLEASE STEP FORWARD. WE NOTE
THAT THERE'S NO ONE IN THE
OVERFLOW ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY COMPACT THE MODERATOR
AND HAVE THE MODERATOR CHECK
PLEASE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
WHO WISHES. TO TAKE IN OPPOSE
POSITION ON THE TELECONFERENCE
ON. FOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION
TO A. B. TEN THIRTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO COMMENTS COMING THROUGH
AT THIS TIME OKAY WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND-
CHECK WITH OUR- COLLEAGUES TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO BE RECOGNIZED ON THE
DAIS- CENTERED ROSAL YES OUR
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR YES-
WHO WOULD YOU PLEASE RESPOND TO
SENATOR ALSO. THANK YOU THANK
YOU- IT IF YOU COULD ON A
PRACTICAL BASIS EXPLAINED- HOW
UNDER EXISTING LAW. THE STATE
AGENCIES- WHEN HIRING FOR THE
SAME POSITIONS INTERNSHIPS AND
STUDENT ASSISTANT POSITIONS.
CURRENTLY ARE REQUIRED TO GIVE
PREFERENCE TO PRISONS. YOUTH UP
TO SIXTY. TWENTY SIX YEARS OF
AGE OF ALL WHO HAVE BEEN
DEPENDENT CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE HOMELESS YOUTH OR FORMALLY
INCARCERATED YOUTH. NOW WITH
THIS BILL WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
SINCE IT'S BASICALLY THE SAME-
LANGUAGE TO GIVE PREFERENCE TO
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
HOW HOW. HOW COULD THAT WORK
HOW DOES SOMEONE. DO THAT AS AN
EMPLOYER DO YOU MIND SENATOR IF
I COULD NOT TURN TURNED TO DO
WELL GOMES. WHO TESTIFIED FIRST
TO THAT WOULD BE FINEYES THE
BRIDGE WILL GOMEZ- THE QUESTION
HAS BEEN TENDERED TO YOU- MY
PLEASURE TRY AND RESPOND TO
THAT AND- SO I WOULD SAY THAT-
BASED ON. THE LANGUAGE IN AB
TEN THIRTY ONE CLEARLY
HIGHLIGHTING THE CRITICALLY.
SURVIVORS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WHERE THEY BELIEVE IN THEIR
CURRENT THE CURRENT BILL
LANGUAGE IT DOESN'T NOT LIKE
YOU TO POINT IT OUT A. B. AFTER
YEARS- AT ANY AGE- REQUIREMENT
BUT- THIS REALLY SPELLED OUT
THE NEED FOR SURVIVORS WHO ARE
OFTEN CRIMINALIZED. AND NOT
NECESSARILY CONSIDERED AN OFTEN
PASSED OVER FOR INTERNSHIP-
INCIDENT THAT THAT PROGRESSION.
I HOPE THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION. RESEARCHER YES ROSA
YOUR THE FORGERS IT REALLY
DOESN'T I'M I'M TRYING TO GET
AT. WHERE THERE IS A CURRENT
PREFERENCE LIST. OF YOUTH
FOSTER CARE HOMELESS FORMALLY
INCARCERATED WE HAVE THE SAME
WHAT APPEARS TO BE THE SAME
LANGUAGE NOW BEING- APPLIED TO
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING. I
DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW ALL YOU
CAN DO ALL OF THAT. OKAY AS AN
EMPLOYER IS- LET ME KNOW IF YOU
DON'T MIND IF I CAN GO TO THE
DA'S OFFICE RIGHT MISSILES I'M
SURE SHE WILL BE ABLE TO ANSWER.
YES THANK YOU. WHAT WE SEE SO-
FOR SEVERAL OF THE VICTIMS THAT
WE ARE WORKING WITH IT IS THE
LACK OF EDUCATIONAL- EXPERIENCE
AT THE HOUSE BECAUSE MANY OF
THEM AS WE SAID HAVE BEEN.
PULLED INTO THE TRAFFICKING
LIFE- WHEN THEY WERE JUVENILES
AND SO IF THEY'VE REACHED
ADULTHOOD A LOT OF THEM ARE
STILL PURSUING ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF OBTAINING YOUR HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA. AND THEN
ADDITIONALLY ALTHOUGH THEY MAY
HAVE- SOME FELONY CONVICTIONS
WHAT WE ALSO SEE IS SOME OF
THEM HAVE EXTREME DIFFICULTIES
IN TRYING TO CLEAR UP THOSE
MATTERS. BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO TRAVEL TO OTHER
JURISDICTIONS AND SELL OUR%
ORGANIZATION THROUGH THE FAMILY
JUSTICE CENTERS WILL HELP THEM-
CLEAN UP THOSE RECORDS. BUT WE
DO FIND THAT SOMETIMES THAT THE
BECAUSE THEY ARE TRAFFICKED
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES WILL
HAVE- CRIMINAL RECORDS IN
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS AND THAT
COULD BE A HINDRANCE FOR THEM
THAT PERHAPS. FOSTER USE MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO BE DEALING WITH.
WHEN SEEKING EMPLOYMENT. MISTER
CHAIR THE SERVER I'M THINKING
HE SAID THE THAT DIDN'T ADDRESS
THE QUESTION AND IF YOU LOOK
AT. IT EDUCATION WE PRIORITIZE
A FOR FUNDING AND- OF FOSTER
KIDS HOMELESS KIDS SPECIAL
NEEDS ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
ONE OTHER IF YOU LOOK AT OUR
SENIOR SERVICES WE- WE
CATEGORIZE CERTAIN POPULATIONS
THAT WE CAN DO WE PRIORITIZE
AND I THINK WHAT THE SENATOR
WAS ASKING IS HOW DOES THIS
MATCH. OR THEIR CATEGORIES THAT
ARE ALREADY PRIORITIZED ANOTHER
WEST MENDOZA SAID TO IT- I
THINK THE CASE WAS MADE FOR WHY
THIS PARTICULAR CATEGORY FITS
BUT THE QUESTION WAS IS ARE
THERE OTHER CATEGORIES MISTER
SIS ONE THAT'S ADDED TO THE
LIST. SAID AND HOW DO YOU DO
THAT I THINK THAT'S SORT OF
WHAT THE SENATOR WAS TRYING TO
GET ADVERSELY SETS WHAT I
INTERPRETED MANY TO SAY. THAT
SENATOR DRAWS A I MEAN THIS.
DOES THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE SO
MANY DIFFERENT BARRIERS.
SPECIALLY FOLKS THAT ARE IN
THIS CATEGORY. THAT THEY JUST
WON'T BE HIRED YOU KNOW FOR AND
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE. I
MEAN IT'S A DOMINO EFFECT RIGHT
YOU GOT- HOMELESS YOUR FIRST
SET. IT DON'T HAVE HOUSING-
WE'RE TRYING TO STOP THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ADD ANOTHER CATEGORY
SO THAT WE CAN HELP IN THE
SYSTEM PUT PEOPLE BACK TO
EMPLOYMENT IT'S- WHAT- MISTER
MISS GOMEZ SAID IT'S ABOUT HOPE
IT'S ABOUT TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN HELP AT THE END AND
WE'RE HOPING THAT WE COULD DO.
BETTER THAN WHAT WE'RE DOING
NOW. DESERT ROSE OKAY I. AM I
TOTALLY SUPPORT. WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO THIS NO DOUBT
THERE'S NO DOUBT IN MY MIND
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO. AND I
WILL. SUPPORT THIS- BILL TODAY
BUT I I'M STILL. YOU KNOW LEFT
WITH THE ISSUE OF IF YOU ARE A
STATE AGENCY. HOW DO YOU TAKE
FEYERICK THESE FIVE CATEGORIES.
AND GIVE PREFERENCE TO EACH ONE
OF THEM. YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD
GUIDANCES THERE SO MAYBE
OFFLINE YOU CAN FURTHER ANSWER
MY ROOMMATE WILLING TO WORK
WITH THE OFFICE TO THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU REMEMBER
SURE. I THINK- I ACTUALLY HAD
THE SAME CONCERN AND QUESTIONS
CENTER DRAWS SO HAS IT WHICH IN
MY- IN MY UNDERSTANDING I THINK
THE QUESTION IS. HOW DO YOU
PRIORITIZE ALL OF THESE GROUPS
WE HAVE ALL THAT EQUAL FOR IT
ILLEGAL LEVEL SO WE HAVE.
SPOROCYSTS YOU APPLY ANY CHECK
THE MARKS IN ORDER TO DEFEAT
THIS CATEGORY THIS CATEGORY
WHEN MAKING THAT DECISION HOW
DO YOU PRIORITIZE- AT WHAT
LEVEL DO YOU PRIORITIZE- THESE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES TO AVOID
THIS THIS PARTICULAR ONE FALL
IN IN COMPARISON TO THE OTHER.
CATEGORIES THAT YOU HAVE TO
PRIORITIZE I THINK THAT IS THAT
WAS MY QUESTION AS A WOULD YOU
FALL INTO THAT LINE OF
CATEGORIZING AND PRIORITIZING.
THIS PARTICULAR GROUP WITH IN
THE OTHER GROUPS THAT YOU
ALREADY HAVE AN IN
CONSIDERATION AND- A PREFERENCE
OUR PRIORITIZATION POINT-
DECIDING ON THESE POSITIONS.
AND I KNOW WE'RE YOU'RE HEADING
WITH IS AND I. TOTALLY AGREE
AND BE WILLING TO WORK WITH
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
PRIORITIZE. I GUESS MY POINT IS
THIS IS THAT WORK WE ARE TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT. THAT THE-
ARE PUSHED. TO QUALIFY THEY ARE
THEY'RE NOT SET ASIDE THEY'RE
NOT PUSHED AWAY. YOU KNOW WE
WANT THEM WE WANT AGENCIES. TO
ACCEPT AND WORK. TO TRY TO HELP
HELP MOST OF THOSE FOLKS THAT
ARE OUR PLANE NOW THAT REALLY
PROBABLY DIDN'T HAVE. A CHANCE
OF HOPE DEAR DIDN'T MMHM MOST
PEOPLE WILL LOOK AT HIM AND SAY
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY MADE
THEMSELVES MAY THINK THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE A SHOT. AND I'M
REALLY TRYING TO PUSH THAT THEY
DO WE WHICH SHOULD ENCOURAGE
MORE. THE PROJECT EXECUTE. THIS
SUMMER I'M SORRY I JUST FEEL
OBLIGATED TO MAKE A COMMENT
AFTER THAT BECAUSE- THERE WERE
TWO DIFFERENT ISSUES HERE. AND
ONE IS ONE OF THE PROCESS DO
YOU USE FOR DEALING WITH THE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES IN MAKING
SURE THEY ALL GET A SHOT. THE
SECOND ISSUE IS MAKING THE CASE
FOR THIS ONE PARTICULAR
CATEGORY. AND I THINK WHENEVER
WE'RE TRYING TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM. OF HOW YOU FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DEAL WITH THE FIVE WE
GET A PITCH FOR THE ONE
CATEGORY. AND I THINK I AGREE
WITH SENATOR DRAWS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE ONE CATEGORY WE'RE
STILL LOOKING FOR WHAT THE
PROCESSES FOR. FOR HOW YOU DO
IT AND I THINK I JOIN SENATOR
ALSO INSIDE. VOTE TO MOVE THE
BILL BUT THAT'S THE QUESTION
THAT WE'RE LOOKING TO HAVE
ADDRESSED GOING FORWARD AND-
IT'LL JUST BE. WE ARE JOKING
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE HALF THE
BILLS WE VOTE ON HERE COME TO
JUDICIARY AND THEN WE'RE DOING
IT AGAIN. BUT I SUSPECT
SOMEBODY WILL BE ANOTHER
COMMITTEE WHERE THIS COMES IN
WE CAN ASK THAT QUESTION AND
I'M SURE HE'LL BE READY WITH
THE ANSWER WHEN THAT HAPPENS.
CREATIONS ACTUALLY. THEY ARE A-
LET ME JUST SAY. MINDERS WHICH
BY THE PRESIDENT INNER THE
AUTHOR AGAIN CORRECT ME
AFTERWARDS AS AS WELL- THE
SOUNDS LIKE THERE MAY BE SOME
CLARIFICATION AT A MINIMUM
NEEDED- OR IF THEY'RE NOT
NEEDED THE- SUGGESTED ALONG THE
WAY BUT I. I DID NOT TAKE IT AS
A COMPETITION OPEN ANYWAY OR
PRIORITIZATION WITHIN THE
CATEGORIES BUT MORE LIKE A
REVERSE BEYOND THE BOX WHERE.
BASICALLY IT'S AB OF SOMEBODY
IS IN ONE OF THESE CATEGORIES-
NOT ONLY SHOULD THEY NOT BE.
EXCLUDED BUT THEY SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED- SORT OF FLIPPING-
WHAT MAY HAVE BEEN- BEEN
OPPOSITE KIND OF A
CIRCUMSTANCE- IN YEARS PAST
THREE DECADES PASS ON ITS HEAD
INSANE. YEAH IF AS TO ALL OTHER
APPLICANTS VISA APPLICANTS IF
THEY HAVE EVEN ONE OF THESE
EVEN ONE OF THESE- TREATS THAT.
THEY SHOULD BE PRIORITIZED AS
TO OTHER APPLICANTS THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING OF IT- BUT MAYBE
THAT'S AN OVERSIMPLIFICATION
AND I CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO
PUT WORDS IN THE AUTHORS. MOUTH
BECAUSE I'M TAKING- MY
INTERPRETATION OF MY OWN
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS HERE. SO-
YEAH THANK YOU THANK YOU THAT'S
THAT'S MARCH MY JOB HERE TODAY.
AND- BESIDES- GIVING EVERYONE
OFF TO WHERE THEY NEED TO GO
NEXT WEEK I MOVED BILL A LONG A
LONG EVENING FOR ALL OF US
STILL SO. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE YOU MAKE CLOTHES IF YOU
WISH. WE DO HAVE A MOTION READY
TO GO FROM CENTER LEARN.
RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN ABOUT.
THANK YOU BERMAN SAID EARLIER
HAS MOVED THE BILL WILL CALL
THE ROLL CALL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
I'M ON THAT COURTESY FIVE. OR
DOES THE AYE BUT CHOI BOGUE HI
THE TROUBLE GUY WRESTLE.
DRESSER I LAYERED HI THERE I
NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE REYES THE
THREE POPULAR BILL UNANIMOUS
VOTE IN THE BILLS OUT THANK YOU
YES I DON'T SEE YOU IN
APPROPRIATIONS. AND I HAVE THE
ONE OF VOTE ON COLLEGE GIVES
YOU THE ABILITY TO CALL ON THE
BLUES AB SEVEN. CONSULTANT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS LAYERED HI THERE
HI. SO THE BILL IS OUT ON THE
FINAL VOTE OF FORTY ONE. THAT
CONCLUDES OUR PROCEEDINGS TODAY
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING AND THANK YOU.
FOR ALL THOSE THAT SUPPORTED
THIS COMMITTEE- IN ITS
ENDEAVORS TODAY- IT WAS AN
INTERESTING AFTERNOON FOR US-
BUT WERE CONCLUDED- TECHNICALLY
JUST IN TIME FOR US TO MOVE ON
I THINK TO THE REST OF THE
SENATE SCHEDULE SO- THANK YOU
ALL FOR THAT AND- THANK YOU TO
OUR CONSOLE. WE ARE ADJOURNED.